the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
kings were crushed in Knights anointed
at the super United rapid and Blitz and
Zagreb Croatia our leader remains
unchanged but a tightly knit pack of
pursuers are hot on his heels it was a
frustrating day for reigning world
champion Magnus Carlson who was
outplayed by shakriar Mama diarov losing
his first game of the event and falling
to the middle of the standings Dutch
Superstar Jordan van Forest demolished
world champion candidate Ian ponyachi to
tie for second place with American
Phenom Wesley so pieces are in place and
the pairings are set day three of
exciting chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to day three of the
grand chess tour behind me the art
Pavilion in the heart of Zagreb will any
of our players create a masterpiece in
the last day of our Rapids let's find
out with our commentators Miro Yasser
and Christian
hello everyone and Welcome to our live
coverage of the 2022 grandchester from
beautiful Zagreb Croatia we are in day
three of the rapid chess competition our
last day of competition in the Rapids
I'm Yasser along with Miro in studio
here in St Louis Miro uh great well
first of all welcome everybody to our
wonderful coverage in Mira I wanted to
ask you about some observations that you
picked up after two rounds yeah well
there's been a lot yeses so first of all
we had quite a few of let's describe it
as good games then we had crazy games
comes to mind yeah right and overall
young guys performing very well was a
bit of a a bit of a surprise and Magnus
one more time steals the show This Time
by you know playing badly losing the
game being in the middle of a pack yeah
a lot of excitement of course wonderful
and uh take a look at the standings and
who's on top Nero yeah who's on top it's
himself alone and if anything he could
have scored more wow or nine points
after uh six rounds yeah at Thai for the
second Wesley saw in Jordan One Forest
and I guess Maxime bushella Graf is also
in the zone exactly two standout names
looking there Magnus Carlson and Jan
Napa two of the strongest players in the
world languishing at 50 or even less
mirror that's quite a surprise yeah
that's a big surprise yes something
happens to Magnus obviously after this
announcement that he steps right from
the wild Krone yeah and our format
format yeah format will I will not
reread it once again it's just a service
announcement to the place it's a lost
day of Rapid City if you guys are
planning to score double points right in
Rapid it's the day to do it now is the
time indeed and our remaining schedule
as being said so today we have around
seven to nine three last rapid rounds
and then starting from tomorrow it's
gonna be a lot of blades 18 rounds in
total and if necessary we'll have a
playoff in the last day wonderful and
Christian nice to see you in studio my
friend what do you think about our
leaders
great to see you guys good to be back in
the studio calling the action of the
best chess players and we have them here
at the Grand Chester and what a
tournament it was but I want to focus on
the top three and we're going to start
with one Wesley so the American who is
extremely consistent in every single
event that he plays and you can see that
from his line score he started off with
a team two draws after that he scored
twice in a row and after that finished
it off in round five and six with two
draws definitely a very consistent
player and he has been showing that
consistency all throughout his career
but in round number seven he has a big
Clash ahead of himself against one
Magnus Carlson after that he will be
facing the current leader Ali Reza
firuja and he will top it off in round
number nine with Shakir mamadiarov
definitely not an easy path in the last
day one other player that I'm having my
eyes on and I told you about yesterday
as well is Grandmaster Jordan van
Forrest a Dutchman who has been
impressing in this event in last year's
event he scored only two victories well
in this event he started with two
victories blazing hot start for this
young man unfortunately for him he fell
under a sharp sword of Wesley sewing
round number three but that game could
have went any other way and after that
in round six that was a demolition with
the black pieces against janepo miyashi
what an impressive two days this young
man has had and of course we have to
talk about his road ahead today a big
opportunity in round seven against
Vaseline topalov who unfortunately for
him is struggling up to this point in
this event after that against Magnus
Carlson in round eight and finishing it
off with a big Clash against Ali Reza
fioruja who is is indeed the man of the
hour right now he is the current leader
in the standings and what a brilliant
start for this young man in the first
day two victories out of three started
blazing hot after that Tamed off in the
second uh day nevertheless he finished
it off in round six against a crucial
Victory against chakra mahmediarov and
let's take a look at his road ahead well
he's starting off against Dominguez who
unfortunately for him hasn't been
showing his abash chess nevertheless
still a very dangerous opponent round
eight against Wesley so and finishing it
off with a big Clash against van Forest
needless to say we're going to have a
lot of exciting games today and we also
have our good friends in Zagreb
Anastasia and Alejandro to tell us all
about the atmosphere in Zagreb guys
thank you Christian and welcome to
Zagreb we are on site commentators I'm
Grandmaster Alejandra Ramirez here with
woman Grandmaster Anastasia carlowicz
we've had a blast so far because guys
it's the last day of Rapids here at the
Grand chess tour but besides the
tournament itself we have a festival of
Chess we've had simultaneous exhibitions
we've had a lot of other things
happening here in Zagreb Anastasia tell
us a little bit about what you've seen
yeah hello everyone hello Alejandro uh
Saint Louis uh yeah I mean there are
some side events here and we know that
kasparaches Foundation invited Ukrainian
Refugee kids here in Zagreb to visit
grantchester but also to take part in
the session with Gary Kasparov and today
the session has started and can you
imagine this pleasure to be present in
the lessons of the world champion Gary
Kasparov himself so I've been there I've
taken some photos I've listened a little
bit it was really nice I mean the
experience for Ukrainian kids especially
during these difficult times and I just
wanted to mention that also all kids
took part in this simultaneous
exhibition which took place after the
opening ceremony and ever somebody on
Goff won Ukrainian great talent he even
made a draw with Wesley saw can you
imagine that it's impressive and
remember it's not just a symbol of a lot
of people he was focused on only four
boards Wesley was and still you are well
he held him to a draw he was a great
game and he's a great talent you were
mentioning he even has a grand master
Norm at the age of 13. yeah exactly I
think maybe even if Guinea knows more
about him maybe he will tell a little
bit after that and what a great result I
mean good training for Wesley so
absolutely he'll neither because Wesley
has a huge bearing to start the day
he'll be playing World Champion for now
Magnus Carlson to start the day guys
back to the studio to see all of the
pairings that await in round seven thank
you Alejandro and thank you Anastasia
what an opportunity of Lifetime to train
with Gary Kasparov that is really
remarkable but Miro please leave the
table for our around seven pairings oops
as we
yeah we have Olive Reza already
has taken his place he is facing
Dominguez yes also a very very important
game for foreign
his uh closest Rivals have both have
white pieces Wesley saw has been said
against Magnus Carlsen and one for rest
perhaps has a chance because he is
against whistling topalov also with
white Apollo is not performing very well
so let's see let's see how it goes
Muhammad yarov against MBL that's a game
to watch yeah that's a game to watch as
well yeah like MBL is still within a
Striking Distance if it if we are
talking about winning the rapid and
sarich faces nipple Nepal well my boy
commentators curse that's what you've
done and there you have even sarich on
the left with the white pieces I wanted
to say that vessel and topolov pardon me
he started the tournament day one with
three losses
day two he rided the ship with three
draws which leaves
for day three and then he'll have gone
through the entire uh sequence uh that's
available there we see uh Jordan on the
left my understanding Miro is that
they're going to take some random person
out of the audience and say how would
you like to make the opening first move
and I must say if they pick Djokovic I'm
gonna say the fix is it what about you
well yeah that would be just something
random person random person that's
always how it goes I believe yes I I
never trust this random random you know
when they pick random person it happens
to be a friend of a friend most of the
times right yes the players are set and
ready I believe we have like a one
minute before this round starts I just
want to say a big shout out to the
Croatian organizers there when I look at
the photos and the videos of the staging
the lighting and the audience it looks
just great I mean as a player I just
feel so good about such venues and one
thing I don't think we can count out is
one player that we cannot count out is
Magnus Carlson right he's only two
points that's Striking Distance behind
Wesley so and you're an advanced worse
and Three Points behind alireza but
right now in round seven well that's a
big Clash against Wesley so this one is
going to be I think uh the game of the
round for us this is the random person
who's the random person
and uh well she gets a smile from uh
Magnus Carlson that's not bad exactly uh
I don't know Miro she looks like she
she's ready to uh push the push the
pieces
D4 for Wesley son I have to say Wesley
saw is better against Magnus Carson
according to this engine running right
you know at the moment at the background
did he keep it on yeah the board no D4
was accepted no I think that we just
switched games there just a this looks
mvl this is the game that yeah d2d4 was
uh the move that Wesley played
surprising well this is the tough part
about uh playing against Magnus is he
deviates with the slav defense that came
out of nowhere in a kind of an
invitation
to play exchange love if you're Wesley
Wesley likes and there you go he does
and for Magnus you know because he plays
the Queen's Camp it declined the groom
felt he could play so many systems
um
how often does Magnus play the slav uh
Christian definitely not very often
right I haven't seen him Place love
almost at all
um and definitely I did not expect
exchange stuff from Wesley so I don't
think I've seen him ever to play this
one he usually goes for the main lines
you know Knight F3 Knight C3 allows the
tasty for and so on goes into those very
long sharp lines but it seems like he
wants a different type of game against
Magnus cars Bishop pardon me Knight H5
that's hitting the bishop that's a very
different wrinkle I mean I I'm not gonna
say it's a novelty because I'm sure it's
been played before but uh definitely off
the Beaten Track there Mira I don't like
this move the last move first place yeah
why I mean knowing how solid Wesley
that's mine
yes that is
Bishop D2 Knight F6 will Wesley even try
I think he has to I mean I've seen him
uh oh no come on
look Wesley I'm the world champion there
we go yeah let's not forget I am the
world champion but with this move E7 E6
he does
in Tomb let's say the bishop on C8 it
would be a kind of an intriguing for me
move Bishop G5 and I really have to ask
Christian once again uh this line of
play it's known uh it has been played
quite a few times actually yes knightway
H5 it seems like we have close to 300
games whoa in this one so quite a few
indeed Bishop to E5 is one of them and
this is actually what I was expecting
from Wesley if he tries to get some more
of an awkward and imbalanced play and
then you have to contend with ideas of
F6 then E6 the Knight is a little bit
oddly placed and then when whenever you
take on G3 you're going to open up the H
file you have to contend with that
because there's going to be an attack
coming against your H7 Pawn every time
you Castle short at the same time you do
a relinquish uh the two Bishops for as
white and that's probably not a good
idea now he decided to go for the very
peaceful Bishop to D2 and then E6 Rook
to C1 still plenty of gains in this
position and uh I'm looking at some of
the top games let's see what we have
right now Nair seems to be one of the
main proponents of this one as well as
Ivan sarich so still quite a few games
have been played in this position
nothing new nevertheless Wesley so I
said it at the beginning of this game he
does not play The Exchange slav so I
don't know how where is of all these
wrinkles
thank you for those insights uh for me I
have played The Exchange love and I must
admit that in my practice nobody played
Knight H5 against me I mean so I
caught unawares by this move now the
move Rook C1 everybody understands Rooks
belong on open files but it's also feels
like white is waiting for black to play
a move like Knight F6 so he could play
Bishop to G5 or maybe bishop to D6 and
in those lines that uh
where you could play uh an F6 uh this
Knight on H5
looks a little bit stranded but I must
admit I I find the whole line rather
confusing myself I uh yeah I will keep
an eye on this what other things
looking well mommy tiarov against Samuel
seems pretty unbalanced if you ask me
whoa because that's what is it somehow
yeah so that's exactly what I was where
I was going so MBL found a way to play
this rashnikov against the English
opening
if you check it
Sicilian special Sicilian with from an
English opening yeah
d683 you can say just trades chaos
Bishop E6 mvl is a natural born Sicilian
player uh Bishop it's a G5 okay so he's
basically saying I don't think you want
to take that pawn yeah
alternative as well because black would
be going D5 right
D5 you're against two Bishops but uh the
development Advantage is huge for blacks
and upon on B3 maybe he's doing very
well Target so Bishop G5 Bishop takes
Bishop
support takes because if you take with
the queen it's it's uh
quite a few jumps yeah yeah the 496 was
a check and the bishop even this
position is not clear yeah Queen E6
Knight takes D6 King E7 and it's yeah
that's another player position but yeah
once again what uh why not why not take
with the pawns as MBL right if you want
yeah he took with the pawn and by the
way he is upon us Bishop G2 F5 this
appears that it doesn't appear in my
database in front of me so I I'm
assuming that's a novelty castles
castles and we're up to date with the
players and actually White had the
opportunity to regain the pawn uh at
that point with Bishop takes C6
and then Queen A4 that would have been
an interesting option
Queen A4 especially due to the fact that
after Bishop E6 Queen takes C6 you
cannot Parry it uh by intercepting that
check with Queen D7 or Bishop D7 because
you're going to lose material so you
have to move the king and lose the right
Castle King to have faith I'm not sure
about that because Rook to D1 is coming
yeah perhaps King E7 is safe maybe King
to E7 is is is uh is the better
placement and then again Castle I put my
Rooks on D1 and I try to Target your
d-pawn as much as possible that was an
option of course you can still probably
play Bishop to D5 this is what I'm
seeing from the position you have to
somehow gain control full control of the
D5 Square so I see that as a potential
with Bishop to D5 what do you guys think
well again that D5 Square so very very
important the compromised the
compromised King side but uh
I would say full compensation but it's
always one of those things when you sit
there and say I have compensation Miro
but do I have Advantage yeah
yeah
there's a thing this compensation right
it's here and it's gone once you once
you yeah by the way it's it's a little
bit old-fashioned evaluation wouldn't
you agree yes like compensation we used
to say it when we there was no engines
and basically there was another way of
saying I have no clue how devaliate this
position yeah I'm some material down but
I have an initiative right yeah I know
it was The Lazy Man's Guide to
annotating games oh yeah compensation
and unclear yeah yeah you know that way
you didn't have to work too hard you
could just stop the thought and continue
but yes compensation and an
old-fashioned conceptual way yeah
because it could mean literally anything
from I have a winning attack for the
pawn I've sacrificed or I'm barely
reaching a draw right right and it's
it's still compensation yeah I've lost
some material I'll probably make a draw
in this position that's that's
compensation do we like Bishop yeah we
probably do like Bishop I was looking at
putting the Rook to D1 but then Knight
D4 was a little bit annoying yeah so
they felt that
excuse me yeah and then if I'm entitled
to play E3 I'm kind of happy right but
rookie 194 is what the noise that might
be three is a threat and I'll have to
make quite a few you know
uh unpleasant decisions perhaps okay so
so this is
c one to C1 kind of inviting maybe once
uh he wants to win the bishop ah yeah so
he's for he would be forced to take
right
so that's uh
Shack's idea that 94 will be met by 95.
very interesting uh we'll keep an eye on
this one I just wanted to check back in
with Wesley to see what he wow 8283 so
just a second Rook C1 Knight F6 here I
thought he would pounce
with Bishop G5 a2a3
I think what he wants is wait for black
to commit the bishop either to D6 or E7
and then put it either on F or put his
own dark Square Bishop either on F or G5
now that black committed on E7 I will
play Bishop to F4 now that opens up the
discussion what are you going to do
after Knight to H5 are you going to go
back and also propose this repetition
once again he had the opportunity to do
that as well after instead of A3 with
the move Bishop to F4 now it seems like
let's wait and see what Wesley is going
to choose to do in this point because
you don't want to play E3 right and last
Bishop on D2 you want your Bishop on the
other side of the pawn chain so Bishop
F4 or Bishop to G5 maybe even H3 yeah
you could try H3 that's what I was
thinking yeah so wait one more move but
then your [ __ ] was confused by four and
then Bishop H2 drop it yes boy what are
all of the uh aggressive youths of
America to make of you yourselves A3 h
take it easy relax relax G4 would
definitely roil the waters we'll keep an
eye on that uh let's just jump to the
game of the Local Hero Yvonne sarich
versus uh nepo for just
whoa we're now we're back into the
territory of this vashnikov a very
theoretical native yeah
oh excuse me of course it is
every time I see these variations
yeah I somehow because that 2018 World
Championship Match where we got these
structures with the Pawn on D5 right
here I think it must be yeah it was
coming from this Washington but it's not
Knight D7 well two Bishops what do you
make of this position
uh yeah it all looks like it went
extremely successful by the night of
Standards it went extremely successful
for white exactly right because by that
point like usually I think those
structures itself they are well black
scores well but objectively it's very
good for wine like white already figured
out how to play it plus Black Diamond
Castle plus he went H6 for whatever
reason and now whenever you Castle G5 I
don't care if I sacrifice a porno
immediately opening the king so black
struggles and the only question is why
on Earth why uh Jan has 25 minutes in
this position could it be it like a
preparation or basically I'm giving away
on this tournament I'm just just like I
don't care I mean so two reasons well
there's no way this is preparation
he's completely busted yeah yeah well
he's completely Bust from an objective
point of view right now the eval is says
something along the lines of plus 2.5
wow so that's completely busted I would
never have guessed and wait it was so
looking at the last like in every line
the G5 move is correct like yes I'm not
but will not overload with you know
computer variation that basically the
main idea so that whenever you try to
live it's like it's always G5 and then
how do you kill G5 likely follow it up
with that what does it do F4 yeah so the
trick is you did not get the bishop on
G7 I think F4 should be done with care
if black is on time to play G6 ICA the
bishop f8 Bishop G7 but it's a little
bit he's a little bit too late I see uh
but again castles G5 H for F4 and I've
always seen neither of players happily
uh escans at night on yeah
but I also have maybe I can take with
the queen you could take with the queen
but what I want to go Queen is Queen E4
or queen F5 and put some pressure if you
allow me to now also the big problem is
that my knight is coming into play right
now so I go yeah
that's another thing yeah so I would
actually still take with the bishop you
know then just Gail Knight D4 and then
Knight C6 the threat Knight F5 is the
threat
the night coming to D4 that is uh that
is a problem really uh an issue for the
Bishops not on F6 if you would have G6
and Bishop G7 I think black would be
perfectly fine I'm beginning to warm up
to the fact that
nepo is it has issues right I mean he
has issues but this idea that he's
stands so badly I I find that really
kind of a surprise because I've Just
Seen seven this looks extremely slow
and now we have green g596 g takes H6 I
mean where is the king where is the
black king going at this point always a
question that you have no way so you're
just nowhere but I've been opening you
up with F4 right well we uh we're about
to see who's getting there first because
Black's idea would to my eyes is
appearing I'm gonna just stay in the
center and I'm about to play Knight C4
that's okay but every time you play
Knight C4 I go Bishop C1 yeah that's
what they do with wine yeah and it looks
like we've concentrated all the forces
against the Kings
it tends to be not enough right
um okay uh does look like nepo who has
been suffering
um
is in trouble by the way sorry uh I'm a
pawn Grabber his uh Knight takes D5 on
tap you want to move and white
apparently well the strongest move for
white is to go F4 it seems yeah and then
you really could take a point by the way
he's done it yeah full played uh an
invitation to go munching if you will
uh no thank you tonight to C4 and again
we talked about the pawn on B2 we
expecting the calm rational Bishop C1
okay let me let me again try to be a
little bit of an advocate for
um nepo's position uh I don't I don't
believe myself by the way
it seems like this one is going to be a
very complex battle nevertheless it does
seem like Yvonne has gotten uh
C4 now apparently he's the strongest
movie perhaps
even though it looks always sacrifices
Bishop takes C4 B takes C4 you open up
the B file don't move your knight and
Yvonne said I had no intention of moving
my light
wow it's all about the black king right
now and the black king is in shambles
E6 Rook F1 I don't think you can take
the piece and that's the problem I mean
I win a I win a a piece but uh I'm
losing Tempe and my king is uh in rough
Seas I'm seeing Rook F1 Rook f8 Bishop
H6
I'm not signing up for that uh this
looks very very
or bad I can't you think of a better
word for Jan something's gone
wrong it's it's it's busted I mean this
one is probably going to be over very
soon wow wow we'll keep an eye on this
I'm gonna jump back to Wesley so guys
let's go to our leaders yeah because we
haven't seen uh Ali Reza's game it's
definitely developing quite nicely and
this is a big opportunity for him
because it does seem like he got not the
better end after the opening battle but
he knows the position better at least
according to the time Spencer that we
have on the clock okay with the joker
piano with uh H3 Knight A6
um
the players actually played very very
quickly linear
on the whites not so quickly for Lanier
only 14 minutes left on his clock and 23
for alireza all right
and uh I don't know Mira my first
thought is if you told me this came from
a Petrov I could easily Imagine That
Knight E5
um
some issues still for black here
I don't think you want to trade and
allow my queen to come to H5 yeah like
one of those positions like first thing
to notice are you think okay the D4 is
an isolated Pawn right but right here I
don't think it matters as a weakness
because how you not ending up exchanging
only five one day exactly I think you
cannot tolerate this night forever so
exactly and yeah moves like Bishop E6
seem to invite not only Knight G5 but
even the potential well I will take the
pawn take this guy and I will sacrifice
in exchange if you allow it also so but
Bishop E6 Knight G5 is just asking for
trouble yeah so we don't expect that but
on the other hand if you do take with
the Knight and I recapture the queen May
land on your doorstep anyway
provoke some weaknesses
um question is where is Black's play
right
25 is so annoying to deal with exactly
um what is the question what is the
engine solution for Ali raisa's
situation well it's not as clear-cut the
engine wants to go Knight F4 Knight G to
F4 try to destabilize it at least we
relieve some of the pressure on the B1
H7 diagonal uh Knight to F4 you probably
want to drop back to F1 otherwise if you
go to C2 well first of all you're not
going to have a clear way to create this
battery but also you have to contend
with ideas of Bishop takes H3 at times
and all these sacrifices I think you
want to keep the bishop next to the king
okay and now the question is okay you
put the Knight on F4 but those Knights
are kind of battling for position with
each other right Superfluous Knights at
one at voretsky said about this
beautiful Knights the problem is
it seems like black wants to play on the
queen side now with the move A4
wow
um not intuitive play which is by any
means intuitive no
no
whoa uh he took 25 Bishop takes C5 he
did Bishop E5 yeah that's much more
human move yeah I was about to say I I
agree with that but it's also made
with a heavy heart because yeah you're
not too bad I'll be doing this but as I
said like you can't really tolerate the
Knight on A5 yeah computer can but for
humans is that it's always this night's
annoying so you just end up trading uh
let's just pursue one or two more moves
Knight takes E5
um again the reason I'm capturing with
the Knight is I want to open up uh the
queen he took with the pawn
but yeah wait a sec if he takes with the
pawn I'll be in time with like I get 94
is one thing Queen C8 I would think
Queen C8 I really want to play Bishop F5
bed
very much so to neutralize I was
actually more of the uh
that I want to get just as Christians
was saying this bishop if I could
persuade you to move your Bishop to F1
F1 then what you wanted was Bishop F5
then uh that that struck me as a very
forcing blow so now perhaps that you
don't have the dark Square Bishop on the
board as black maybe I can play the move
Bishop to E4 and not have to worry about
any sort of like checkmates or yeah
so this is nice
yeah we maybe we have to adjust a little
bit we just see the king with white yeah
and how about the central play like we
go Queen C2 we go to D1 something right
maybe we're just better this way too I
think you have to stop Knight D3 right
right and Bishop D5 of
well at least I I I feel like I've uh
yeah successfully traded up and then
Queen takes and now I'm guessing Knight
E6 you lose an exchange to Bishop uh
before right discover the attack and if
Knight D5 then Harry the H Pawn it's
very standard in such positions like you
have the Knight on G6 it's very good it
defends the king and so on but what it
allows is the eh Pawn starts marching
and the the the tempo game yeah well
we'll just definitely keep an eye on
this one too as our tournament leader
seems to be and they're a little bit of
pressure still has what he's doing great
sometime I I think this is quite
important because domingue is only 12
minutes on the clock this is not going
to be an easy position by the way we do
have a different uh take all together
after Knight F4
not Bishop E4 but Bishop C2
and uh and we expect Bishop to E6 right
quickly open up that and he didn't play
it Bishop E6 idea
you know to rewrite okay let's go back
for just a second one of the things
strategically speaking is your pieces
you want them on effective squares you
take a look at this bishop and mirror
the first thing you said is play Queen
C8 and put your Bishop on an effective
Square uh Ali Reza had a different
approach here but something very similar
he said that his Bishop would be very
very nicely placed on D5 it will hit
that guy on F3 it will defend on F7 so
he was looking for peace rearrangement
and Lanier said I gotcha I know what
you're talking about I am not going to
let you play Bishop D5 and Knight E6
Rook E4 and that movie looks very very
troubling he's the Knight if Knight D5
then I probably have a 1994. exactly
that's uh that was well timed a great
move by uh Lanier provided of course
Knight D3 doesn't cause a mistake and
Rook D4 looks like a great answer so
I like this move a lot
and I think I'm really warming to
Lanier's position as our tournament
leader well guess what he took a step
backwards an indication
of something amiss Knight D4
a very good point yesterday uh I think
with Alejandro when he got interviewed
he said that he feels he plays well but
he also feels that he plays fast so that
means in this tournament he's very
confident and that's not easy to do
after a disastrous candidates that this
young man has but it just goes to show
that he's maturing he's able to go past
those bad results and just simply take
it one tournament at a time and right
now he really wants to make a splash in
this tournament
94 uh yeah we always forget he's so
young 19 years of age so much talent
Knight to D4
and um yeah this definitely looks like
Lanier has a much Superior position 11
minutes on the clock
could be an issue but Miro this is uh
our tournament leader stumbling out of
the gate at the start of round seven
what uh games what makes me close my
eyes yeah that's Nepal's position which
is like Beyond you know any any
Redemption absolutely and and it looks
I don't know if you would argue with me
but it looks exactly the way he lost
yesterday's game against one Forest
that he missed some he was you know
combinative play by his opponent it was
really strange it left a very strange
feeling so that you misplay the opening
to such an extent that you really have
to be careful and then all of a sudden
you decide to be a principal and go for
the sharpest variation you know right
and so on and take whatever is sacrifice
to you and what could possibly go wrong
I guess a lot actually uh first question
was that in this position Yvonne played
a very decent move H5 no no issues with
that move I just wanted to make sure
yeah exactly just want to make sure that
D6 does not win it doesn't win yet but
this is the exact point yeah sir exactly
you want to play H5 so then you play D6
and then you run with the H Pawn after
Bishop takes so this one I just wanted
to make sure that this was not uh
winning uh funnily enough our King is
nicely tucked in yeah and this is the
moment where you say why did I type
no combination for you D6 H5 by Evon D6
is coming and uh yeah I was thinking the
the one thing one reason is
still decent that's the point yeah you
cannot stop because you will end up
taking with the bishop yeah you can
trade a pair of fruits but you will end
up taking with division H6 comes in this
one H5 is a great move and lastly uh
no I don't think I have the time
maybe I don't get to put my night or
perhaps Queen F5 Knight G3 so I have to
be a bit careful
um maybe Queen to E3
same idea not to allow my knight to D6
because it supports H6 in some cases
yeah yeah that's that's just that's the
disaster one last little rub you know oh
by the way aren't you allowing H6 now
that your queen is on E3 uh yeah
um
somehow I saw some line where the bishop
was taking on f8 and I said I didn't
want to have anything to do with this uh
very disposition and H5 looks like well
Yawn is going down in in Flames here
looks like game over right yeah
um a game that uh we haven't uh taken a
look at but Jordan Ben Forrest uh
tied for second uh certainly looking at
vesselyn's track record in the
tournament and saying you're not doing
very well I will like to take advantage
of your poor results and what do you
reckon about this position I don't know
maybe like the polo is not aware that
the one Forest is in great shape because
I really like Black's position me too C4
is a very important Motif that might be
three very often like at first glance
you think okay the bishop only seven is
stupid and the Knight is great right but
in reality Knight B3 takes on C1 and
then you go F5 you go Bishop F6 and all
sudden Bishop is better than the Knight
it's on many occasions I've seen ding
lair in to mention one name another
Lavon aronian comes to mind where these
bishops come alive
quiet passive uh Bishops so not uh I'm
not sure where it went wrong this looks
like a chigore and with D3 yeah okay
Lopez and black yeah black really went
for some sort of chivalry and set up
right
that's really time consuming white was
trying to do right he's spending
especially C4 and then computers on D5
was the bishop the very next move right
uh I would have probably gone for Bishop
D2 something a little bit softer myself
but 95 and we get here
um your take uh Christian what has
caught your eye in this round seven well
what has caught my eye is how well
Vaseline is playing in that one that's
definitely quite impressive and he is
garnering quite an advantage in that
game now also one game that we have
looked at the beginning of the round but
we haven't since is the game between
Muhammad yarov and vashir and muhammadi
Arab is pretty much taking over at this
point if not completely winning already
so he got his Pawn back and an extra
Pawn so he got some dividends for that
one as well quite a nice situation for
my media Arrow then we remember he
started extremely slowly uh at this
tournament but right now with the
potential Victory he could be picking up
the pace I really like what he's doing
in this game against uh mvl
wow well which begs the question what
did he do because when we left it we
thought uh mvl for the pawn uh yeah that
white did have a conversation he started
taking pawns yeah I was about to say now
E7 was a an invitation to capture which
was readily accepted
I'll take them right I think he deserves
a membership yes
Pond Grabbers Association but with this
move Queen C2 uh
[Music]
I feel like I just hit a a dead end
right and after that I'm just going to
push my pawns agree no A4 to be
protected nicely protected by the bishop
then B5 and then I'm going to get off
this pin just annoying pin in the
meantime I don't see as black what your
plan is yeah just a little uh unraveling
moves uh King G2 Queen D2 and as you
said just push the pawn and your Pawn
structure is quite damaged as well I
will also have with the queen on D2
ideas of Queen to G5 at all times you
have to be very careful maybe keep the
Knight on E6 any so you want to go to C4
well well one of the things whenever I'm
playing against the light Square Bishop
I want my play now to go on to the dark
squares so in a dream world I would play
you know E3 and Knight G4 so let's go A4
let's defend that pawn let's defend the
pawn absolutely and can I play E3 you
can try well it's legal it's legal
I I I want to play for the dark squares
and if you do take I'm going to make
some I probably have noise now Queen to
D3 or queen to D let's say queen to D2
actually well in both cases in both
cases I was going to take and again I'm
not happy I'm still maybe suffering
after Queen takes up but at least you're
getting somewhere no right he has played
95 by the way uh did
um mvl and
again I do what can I say I I like the
extra Pawn but I think it's necessary
for MBL to try his best to create
something on the dark squares otherwise
you just lose you just get dragged to
your doom and create it immediately
because white doesn't have kind of a lot
of it doesn't need a lot of myths to
build up
and you're winning exactly they're
following uh the the path that we just
paid yeah a408 yeah well actually that
was A4 perhaps wasn't uh the best myth I
think I just missed E3 E3 which is a bit
strange right because you see the Knight
hanging around your king you do feel
like there has to be something right
connected to E3
and once again Miro this is my one
moment every broadcast these guys are
good
they're so good I think the fact that he
came up with ideas really present uh E3
uh how I mean it's better for white but
how do they lost his Advantage pardon he
actually lost his Advantage ah he
completely lost his Advantage wow okay
so E3 and the line that was serious is
probably the best way forward okay okay
so it means A4 was uh mistimed no uh it
was actually Queen to C2 that was
mis-timed ah so what you had to do is
get rid of the pin as fast as possible
in that at that point with the move King
to G2 Knight coming to D4 and your queen
is forced to go to A4 you don't feel as
comfortable right on D4 is a pre-banded
place actually despite the fact that it
looks so good it's going to get hit with
E3 and that's going to uh solidify my
position at the same time gotcha
I must admit that uh the when you put
your queen on A4 your your first
reaction is I'm doing it wrongly exactly
but then when you say okay but with the
King on G2 you've broken the pin uh
maybe you've done it correctly and uh
295 it's already not that easy you have
to give up the a pawn in fact you have
to still go King to G2 right now and try
to take advantage of the weak King
rather than the extra Pawn allow black
to take on A3 and just try to play
against uh the black king but it's not
as easy of a mindset after you've been a
pawn up you don't want to give it away
and this is unfortunately at this point
it's just uh pretty much a four-straw
okay we'll definitely keep our eye on
this one Wesley so
uh you know it's funny when I left it I
our Honest Engine the bishop was on D2
are you tell me how it got to be too I'm
not even exactly sure there's a lot of
stuff he said a lot of stuff is
happening again the Bishops is on D2
it's not intuitively obvious how it gets
to B2
but this is how it got there okay and E5
Magnus scales for a breakthrough and
Bishop F5 doesn't even bother to play E4
right right yes Rook C7 simply he wants
to get out of this pin maybe maybe the
move the immediate E4 maybe encourages
Knight E5 Yeah well yeah D5 might end up
being hanged right or here well actually
this is kind of uh there's also a motif
of going Knight F3 check maybe oh yeah
so like first and then caption C8 yeah
okay so there were some there were some
reasons to say interesting ideas he
didn't do it and we and we caught up
with the players
so now so now yes uh takes D7 is one
thing
which would be very you know
very much in style of Wesley so I'm
guessing like take these seven so now
you can't really take I thought because
like this is my C2 is hanging right ah
yeah Knight takes D5 right then no then
Bishop takes D7 is pointless yeah
exactly sorry wait wait a second can you
take on E5 and then take on D5
all the all the black pieces are nicely
placed right well I don't know
I don't know I mean you can take on F3
and kind of damage my Pawn structure but
I still control the G5 Square so
more or less happy
and how do these guys do Head to Head
wow
they they've been around the block wait
a second they've played a lot
a lot of more than 100
120 plus rapid games against one another
and by the way we talked about the world
champion dominating as Rivals I mean
Wesley's gotten into shots 21 wins
against the world champion by 53 losses
once again more than twice as many wins
for Magnus Johnson and I think the
number of games he has said for those
two standing it's outstanding it mostly
thanks to this so-called Magnus tour I
don't I can't remember how it's called
properly but the online water yes
Magnus Carlson tour and uh yeah with
chasable and all of the sponsors there
um by the way uh I just thought it was
kind of impressive and definitely worth
mentioning that Magnus is black
he gets into a exchange slaw of defense
and refuses a repetition
no no quick draws for you guys yes I
think we should uh get back to the nepo
game because I think we're going to see
a resignation anytime soon well that
will very
there's another queen Coming that's a
white Pawn on H7 that is the Dominguez
actually that is the Jordan van Forest
versus the Apollo yeah this is it this
is the sarit yes game and when we left
it he's Evon uh we he played into that
line that we looked at Rook to B6 D6
well played the bishop had to give up uh
control of the H6 Square because uh
Queen takes if you if he recaptured with
the queen F7 and that would be
resignation
exactly he had to take with the bishop
but that allowed the H Pawn to trundle
up the board that's the second Queen and
you called it before we even got here
Queen
not only that but Rook to E5 is coming
that that that's another big problem
there we go yeah this is it yeah there
we have it nepo uh
uh wow
I didn't see that one coming
guys neither did you he did not spend a
single a minute to get to a completely
losing position yeah that that's my
problem with nepo I mean not okay
results result is one thing but right
how do you end up like in a lost
position not spending any time and then
look I mean he did spend more than 10
minutes on this game but what's the
point starting to think in the Lost
position yes something is wrong
something's off with them but this was
the typical nepo a couple of years ago
until he found his consistency yeah he
was playing this type of tournaments
where he was just completely off maybe
uh that decision of Magnus Carson to not
play the world championship affected him
in that he right now doesn't see a clear
goal a clear rabbit to chase ahead of
himself who knows but he's definitely
shook after that decision in this
tournament all right interesting by the
way uh we saw the the video from the
playing Hall again Ivan sarich is the
local hero in the former Yugoslavia and
I played in numerous tournaments there
when the Local Hero has won against the
big uh foreign rival the audience is
cheering at Applause and the Arbiters
are waving frantically sit down sit down
and there's whistling
nobody is stopping the audience from
enthusiastically
embracing uh the the victory so our
congratulations to you Yvonne I believe
it's his first win he's
and he is with Alejandro and Zagreb
let's shoot on over
thank you guys we're here with an early
winner of today's round Ivan sharitch
everyone I have to prepare against you
once for one of my students and I
thought man this is a player that likes
to take the bull by the horns and today
that paid off very well uh yeah he
allowed me to to play my game so to say
and instead of Some solid lines like
what he used to play like Petro for
or Berlin or French if you choose this
neither variation and to be honest stage
six was a move which I don't recall so
much I mean nowadays they don't play it
to be honest during the game I
I had no idea why or what to do but
because white has in general like uh
castling is normal but then afterwards
like you can play H4 you can play King
B1
also what can mix up some plans so it's
a bit tricky but it's like an old line
we see some of the games in the database
from Gary good old stuff Gary still
running around with his kasparagus
foundation here teaching some of the
Ukrainian talented kid tell me exactly
where he went wrong where you felt that
it was over okay the main idea of H6 is
to stop G5 and to secure this Knight on
F6 which secures the D5 square but the
problem black has almost he can never
castle of there's this H6 because after
H4 he's just getting checkmated so he's
trying to play on the queen side with
quick B5 B4 idea so Knight b694 or 94 is
in the game but during the game I felt
like maybe Queen C7 was not necessary
I'm not sure increases have another way
okay yeah the engine seems to hate the
move Queen I thought Knight B6 he will
go anywhere and I didn't I thought that
I will just leave this Pawn on D5
hanging and play G5 anyway or even F4
isn't interesting
because if black takes on D5 then Knight
db6 of course and now I don't know
either like F4 or G5 I was considering
G5 right yeah because if Knight D5 I can
go Bishop P4 and have a
domination on the light squares after he
probably has to take only three Queen E3
and then I have strong Square on D5 and
again he can't Castle
maybe skip after G5 plays H5 and then
somehow manages to consolidate but I
thought this was you came up with an
interesting peace sacrifice here you
took on C4 today okay when I see plus
four plus four here I have no like
during the game it was all all very
unclear to me but
so it wasn't clear to you at this moment
when did you feel no this I liked very
much because I had this feeling that the
open files
your favorite white here and I thought
white has more than just one way to win
this game uh yeah I had some small
decision whether to take with the c Pawn
or with Dave Pawn but I think it's
better with it because sometimes when I
take on this scene if he takes with the
queen I have Bishop F4 winning the
exchange and then he has Queen G6 check
if I take with the c Pawn so you wanted
to close the diagonal of Jesus
crushing Victory to start the day here
how's it feeling yeah finally a victory
I didn't have much chances only in
second round I was completely winning
against my major but uh
it feels like I've the games I've lost
which I lost I should not I could have
drawn drawn them and uh
but in general I think I'm satisfied how
I played the openings and the middle
games but in the end games when I was
long time I was doing some very bad
decisions in first two days well no need
for an end game here he did not survive
even the opening Yvonne congratulations
on your win guys let's go back to the
studio we still have four games left
absolutely uh congratulations Yvonne I
was going to say very very convincing
yeah when indeed mineral that wow
shaken I was going to say poor nepo
there uh turning our attention to the
game of Jordan then Forest versus Bessel
and Temple off for just a moment Jordan
has just played what to me visually
looks like a very impressive move move
Queen H5 suggesting excuse me but uh am
I about to sacrifice a piece well wait a
second yes Apollo just make a mistake
was a fight because yeah now I don't
really know now it's not like I have a
better move right between H5 it really
looks dangerous well exactly I mean you
might be thinking for example a move
like Bishop G5 even for that matter
and just say I want to defend upon when
he played this move F5 this was really
an invite you know the desirable Queen
D2 has a drawback The Rook is hanging as
well as the pawn which C8 is something
perhaps that you are limited to or
careful yeah so how bad is how bad is it
that is my question Bishop takes I was
just yeah page six and he played it he
did play working okay I take I have to
accept that sacrifice okay so check how
is this check and we have a lot of them
we collect the pawn but we pause because
Rook lifts yes you can definitely try
that but Rook to E3 don't I have F4
um e-pawn is hanging the a pawn is
hanging you have to give a check first
because yeah let's let's put it on the
board so rookie three it seems like
you're only trying to be honest I mean
yeah if I'm playing for the win a
Perpetual check is always an F4 and then
we ask you to give a check a check
which allows me to take this take
another pawn and by the way that's a big
collection how many pawns is that three
that's three already three are already
in the pocket and I O Bishop xh6 is on
the board guys well I mean from Jordan's
point of view yeah absolutely risk-free
sacrifice that's the conceptual point
it's it's exactly the opposite for the
problem that you want to be right
because it's a anti-free role the
opposite of free role right yeah you
either lose or if you're lucky you make
a draw right now especially with only
two minutes on the clock now the
question for me if I'm in vessel and
shoes I'm probably not taking on H6 can
I bail out with some silly move Queen E8
is not exactly
great but maybe that's what you have to
do but maybe I just have to say look I'm
a pawn down and I've got to play a bad
ending okay so how is that position yeah
[Music]
if the bishop has to drop back at least
you take the open fight exactly at least
I do yeah have that I would like to uh
draw back to F4 yeah
you go to F4 G5 window A8 was played
what queen A8 give me the D5 Pawn really
what is that Queen A8 but this allows
the queen to infiltrate via G6 very
dangerous played by topolov
it looks wrong uh sorry it just looks
six Bishop F6 right for now
nothing terrible happened yeah
but how about but then I can take the B
file right yeah how about Bishop takes
King takes Rook G3 you're getting
aggressive that's dangerous that looks
scary yeah that looks scary yeah it
looks terribly scary uh Bishop takes G7
Christian is the engine approved it's
engine approved it does seem like Queen
2 G6 is just a better play actually oh
yeah Queen G6 is stronger because yeah
yeah you yeah
whenever you uh black captures on D5
Rook to B1 Rook to B1 you're you're
basically taking over a strategical play
in the position
Rook to B1 oh yeah I mean I've been
focused
Monopoly against your king but perhaps
not right now wait for black to take on
D5 first okay in fact Force black to
take on D5 after Queen G6 Bishop F6 go
Bishop to F4 attacking the pawn on D6 I
see
absolutely and that one is definitely
one of uh the games that we should be
following but also there's a lot of
things that are happening in the Wesley
versus Magnus game so we will be looking
at this one in just a second it does
seem like the position Magnus has gained
a lot of space on the king side and in
the center as well and manage to take
full control or at least uh challenge
white on the C file I see Bishop to B4
is coming on the board it's definitely
Magnus who's on the initiative and uh
this one nevertheless I'm looking at the
times as well Wesley so with only five
minutes and 50 seconds and Magnus with
two minutes on the clock and Dominguez
versus fieruja well that one is exciting
as well and maybe you guys can take that
one over because there's a lot of PC
swarming around the black king
nevertheless fioruja is keeping cool
calm collected and maybe repels White's
attack with an advantage I think well
it's one of those games where it's too
big issues versus two nights miroi I
have to say that the modern players of
today
this one upon the non-being the
exception nobody likes to play the
knights but for rouge's Knights at least
have great support squares great
outposts D5 and F5 your need your take
would you rather play white or black
yeah well it really depends in this
position you can't really be specific
yes I think it's very move specific and
I can't imagine like even moves like
Knight E3 being considered for Black
Knight F3 I think you can take with the
pawn right
if Bishop E3 I'm just taking with
another Knight but then some Rook G6
might happen that's what I'm that's what
I'm saying you can't just look at this
position and say okay I like whites I
don't know Bishops I like black spawns
right outposts it's very very like time
sensitive like you you make one room in
fact that's probably the only thing that
helps why that saves white in that
position after Knight to E3 Rook takes
G6
Ellen here it's down to like one minute
only uh Lanier versus
um yeah this one
in only one minute foreign
wow well like kind of keeping an eye on
the C1 Bishop so yeah if anything uh
perhaps protecting D5
preventing preventing Bishop takes on
some E6 who knows
um threat of Knight G7 and Rook F2 yeah
um Queen G5 Queen to G5 dodging the
threat of maybe Knight G7 and Rook takes
F2
37 seconds for Dominguez by the way
there's no Knight D5 in this case allows
Bishop takes E6 at the end of the line
let's go Knight before that
Knight D4 sure why not yeah look Knight
D4 Attack One Bishop three seven
threaten Knight E2 as well he kills
Knight G7 so it wants to be safe opens
the f file I was attracted to this move
especially when in the night when the
queen was on H5 the queen on G5
now but still you target the F2 Pawn
right so this is the question if I take
on D5 do you take on F2
Dominguez
um yeah we you start I really want to
take on that too you know everything
but it doesn't work yeah no just right
okay but if we drop back to B6 I'm
assuming the Rook is going to drop back
the C2
and yeah then I'm safe yeah black uh-ish
safe fish but then I can get the Knight
D4 back Queen A7 is strange okay
defending F2 uh and as you say Bishop D5
in the air
although I don't feel that's like the
greatest threat that you've ever uh it's
been very unclear because Bishop it's a
fine go the other diagonal yeah
we're going to see a resignation there
we go
in the game between
lost this game
oh my goodness look we left the check
position yeah the final position is just
you know I remember uh this comment uh
now I forget who to ascribe it to be
careful who you invite for dinner
you know the tiger may not realize that
it's on the menu uh the pawn on E3 was
never captured and this final move Queen
H4 uh introduces a mate and that was it
wow uh what a turnaround that was
because we thought white was for Choice
let's jump back to the Lanier game and
we do have Rook C2
and uh this three results three result
game
Christian oh absolutely three results
game this one is but let's go to the van
Forest one because I think that one will
uh be finishing up shortly he's
definitely breaking through got one Pawn
to the good and now he's ready to get
some more material in the position is
really looking good for Van forest and
Van Forest guys I mean he's having right
now the tournament of his life no
question about it he just clipped as you
said a second Pawn gift me some Pawn
give me some funds and also uh Vaseline
with only 30 seconds 50 seconds excuse
me on the clock well that's not actually
like the way one Forest keeps the Queens
on the board right yeah well perhaps
jumped at the chest yeah as myself I'd
consider exchanging the Queens being
pulled up on everything exactly against
topolov who is lower on the clock it's
also very like very annoying practical
play like you have to be aware of those
Queens yeah Bishop F4 just cover the
diagonal Rook B1 is only one check right
yep
by the way the other reason I really
like the move Bishop F4 is it kind of
takes away any issues of Queen G3 and
Rook B1 Bishop F4 uh domination
domination 5 is coming right now you are
pretty much busted absolutely
um wow
I'm really stunned that nobody on panel
sure wait a second I have to say the
reason well not completely unrealistic
scenario that one four is going to be
leading the tournament as well because
as we said three results and Wesley so
might be in a bit of a trouble against
Magnus Carlsen believe it or not let's
jump to that Wesley so Magnus Carlson
because you're absolutely
wrong
uh no that night is coming to G5 to F2
even though it remains yeah the bishop
is it dead really or there is some way
that he'd be sacrificing on B5 or this
or that yeah because with dark Square
Bishop on D6 let's say oh it's over it's
like The Bishop's gonna go to B4 Knight
to F3 and win yeah here Bishop is
somewhat useless on B7 so exactly but
I'm looking this night coming to to F3
and frankly I would be terrified and
with this move Knight the Knight e2d to
my eyes Wesley wants to play Queen
and maybe just run with the King giving
right or 1992
or at least want to exchange that well I
wanted to keep the queen actually off of
the C4 Square
during the D5 Pawn I'm not allowed to do
that the bishop C8 yes Magnus brilliant
he's not bad at this kid he's not bad
that's a 95 Queen D2 obviously yes yes
I'm actually not sure if the move is
good though but anyway we spoke about it
enthusiastically and we passion is
crucial in our sport Knight F3 by the
way yeah like that's the threat deadly
that's right wait a second if you trade
even G takes F3 and the bishop is no
longer that pointless but you also have
ef3 and then you open the diagram I must
say I'm not a fan of this move King G2
here if you ask me I would get on my
walking shoes and I would Sprint to the
queen basically you're leaving the H2
behind yeah go ahead yeah take it it's
all yours and I want my king to be safe
and I want you you to maintain this
bishop on uh kind of a kind of a block
King G2 Knight F3 and I hear you loud
and clear any captures of this Knight
will bring that Bishop to life yeah by
the way there was no rush to play the
move Knight F3 Bishop well he realizes
what you just belatedly belatedly though
but that's a pawn
and Magnus said that's a pawn that's a
pawn and then you return to F3 and you
stay there pretty much forever because
yeah it can never be captured right but
King E1 Knight F3 King D1 and you still
have to prove prove it yeah the problem
is that after you get the king to D1 I
don't think you can go to C1 because
that allows Knight E1 Knight D3
and that might be deadly so you have to
stay with the King on D1 to defend the
E1 square but it just feels like you're
completely tied up white is so
overloaded right I mean just covering
everything he's playing Bishop E6
doesn't happen and then queen of Faith
queen h8 queen H1 yeah
by the way the players are beginning to
rush their moves a little bit an
indication to my mind that somebody's
short on time both of them are around
one minute whoa
excuse me with one minute I'm sorry
that's a three result game even though I
like Black's position one minute
whoa 0.37 don't take on D5 Queen to G5
is going to capture the Knight yeah
Knight takes D5 Queen G5
yeah just just the Spain is terrifying
but I actually somehow I wanted my queen
to get into game night D Queen Knight C3
to B1 and maybe Queen C3
he did not play it he played Queen B2
I like getting the Knight back to F3 of
course I'm not sure why he's not he's
looking for some sort of 194 D5 trick
about this the queen to B2 King to G7
battery or whatever opposition and
they're looking for some tricks the
funny part is I was looking to play
Queen A3 uh and queen F6 I he tricked uh
Magnus a little bit but he goes to d8
Magnuson still controls all the all the
you know the squares right
now
maybe it's time for King D1 and Knight
E2 to F4 that looks like an improvement
Queen
this allows me to go Queen to age eight
that we have a result we have a result
wow Jordan as he explained in an
interview with Alejandro he won two
games at one of these rapid and Blitz
Grand Chester events he started with two
wins and now he has another one uh in
his collection and for Vaseline a bad
tournament is getting worse uh
we can't take on e4 and take the bishop
at the end because there's a queen D3
accident Queen D3 check accident in the
position oh he's done it actually says I
can do it I don't believe are you sure
23 King D1 and I understand it looks
terrible but how do you beat me from
here is it necessary I'm not sure I
can't believe that um
if it holds it's just amazing okay well
I have to take
and I'm kind of tied down but do you
what what's the king I will be upon up
with the King upon ending but maybe the
pawn isn't so brilliant I mean you can
get it even in a better way with Queen
two uh F6 right
but do you get it though actually no
because yeah that's exactly what Magnus
is doing King D1 and apparently he's
gonna play King of fate
Queen F6 might not be the best
you could think of three are you on time
kind of trading on on eight seconds for
Magnus eight seven
I'm telling it's a three nine three
weeks old game do not listen time Magnus
please Queen went back played with three
seconds on the clock how many seconds
three seconds he smokes
three seconds now it's all equal
according to the machine no why is it
how Wesley wiggled his way out it's
unbelievable how why is this equal
Magnus is collecting the pawn on E6 I I
was about to say this is a great can I
try to create my counter play with when
cc2 is the myth for white apparently
so that if I trade that's exactly the
one that now King C1 maybe Queen C2 and
now it's Queen C3 oh that's a check and
then queen king to C2 yeah you you kind
of have to make more and more Awkward
moves and now what king G8 there is a
check
don't you just lose what's the time
eight seconds for Magnus
go King H7
how do you say with trembling hands
right English six did he blunder his
point to C7 followed by king queen to C6
perhaps
Queen d8 so I like that it's a little
bit of a check from a Chase right
G5 I'm a little bit surprised that
Magnus doesn't repeat once or twice uh
just to get the time you know just you
know move like King H7 Queen C7 check
King H6 I'm saying gain 20
aesthetic guns on the clock and again
what about Wesley 42 seconds for Wesley
but Magnus right now with 34 seconds he
gained a lot of seconds
so with this G5 why isn't uh Magnus for
choice
well the problem is how do you make any
progress
because now the queen and this uh
finished being a drop means a
well-fought battle between them
two co-leaders right in your until this
game is finished exactly so that means
really Wesley would need the win to join
to catch up okay
so he hides the King on G2 that's the
plan right well makes a lot of sense
somehow it feels like the black king
right now is the weaker one now wait a
sec we put the Knight on G6 and then
looking yeah looking for a four and also
it guards
Knight C4 is uh your B6 Pawn is hanging
Knight C4 mirror after the Knight moves
right now the Knight on E5 does a great
job to
by the way is Wesley weren't worming his
way away
King G2 had somehow White's King feels a
little safe now
you cannot move the Knight because of
Knight the queen can't move Black's
Queen can't move
at least and hang the Knight on E5
again the clock time's very close he's
dropping down to his last five seconds
Max no you have to make a move Magnus
don't forget about the time one second
on the clock how much
second and F4 is terrible I have to tell
you because white just captures it twice
guys
are going to win this game world
champion
it's going to be three-way tie
wow
Knight C4 you don't even have a threat
that Force protected exactly 1993 and F5
Knight C4 give me the pawn on B6
and he's done it he plays it Queen takes
B6 is not really happy right now wait a
second at least we can take on F4 now
Knight F4 Queen F4 Queen takes C4
Jack yeah but that's even materials oh
good points probably I mean you're
getting enthusiastic when I realize uh
before he's on the board
four players have calmed down a little
bit perhaps he was better off going to
F1 with the same idea to get the Knight
to E3 Wesley we do we have Queen takes
G4 checking F6 on the board
this was an escape for both players
exactly yeah like save so sometimes you
have those games where both players are
really
relieved like you've got enormous sense
of relief
it is it is still not over that King
could potentially go towards B4 how
about Queen to uh B8 right here right
now and just say okay
uh make a move
Queen to be eight make a move well it's
I mean if I'm too scared Queen E6 should
be should be good enough when age sick
is is what Wesley does okay he didn't go
to B8 but H6 Queen D4 that's a good move
right very nice Central defending
everything
well the position is equal but the
feeling is that they both looking for
the way to you know they may be
hopefully E3 uh E3 is E3 a good sound
ether is an invitation for uh for a draw
of course
but it ah there'll be one of those
things that
it's possible you could also be
blundering the E Pawn right but I don't
think you can get uh it's kind of
serious you have to stay back
on the E7 Square so you basically stay
76 right
yeah
wow uh
both players I I do believe we have a
three-way tie for first guys no no no no
no not yet no right now
needed to win two-way tie for first yeah
I beg your pardon three decisive results
out of five games we've been seeing this
throughout especially day one a high
number of decisive games and
let's jump to Zagreb uh with Alejandro
and mvl
thanks guys we're here with a winner of
round seven Maxine vashir lagraf seems
like you were having a little bit of
trouble there with shock but counter
play was found yeah certainly I didn't
dwell in the opening and yeah my
position was beyond suspicious so here
shark just grabs a pawn I thought maybe
Queen C5 made sense it looks like it
does just then maybe to follow up with
you it was
yeah not
I don't know but anyway it took then I
went rock C8 and all d8 and somehow here
I found counter prep which I shouldn't
have found yeah I guess history yeah
history was called for then I probably
can just resign and then suddenly E3
comes
and I guess you should take but of
course it's sad to
to make a draw here right you just f2f4
Suddenly It's very tricky so like Kim G2
Knight G6 and my queen softer b5h5 let's
say my queen is contouring the pawn on
A4 so no majority can advance I do
threaten things on the king side I mean
dark squares are always open so the
bishop cannot move because of the queen
so because the bishop cannot move the
queen cannot move and like even let's
say you have Queen on D5 Bishop on B3
like okay let's play some Honda move
you go Bishop is here I still go Queenie
one you take and it's made yeah you're
just not saving yourself yeah being
alone me too so that means it's very
tricky to play and here
yeah this I was not sure but I thought
it's very tricky because Kenji to Queen
H4 is almost made and apparently there's
a Save which
is beyond difficult to find yeah and
backward maneuver and then no I mean I
saw this idea but not with looking on H3
which has no move but anyway it seems
like so after King F1 and I start for a
while about 95 Knight C4 but there's
Queen D5 Queen G5 check
and I was like am I gonna really make a
draw here and then I found this very
nice maneuver with Knight f8 absolutely
beautiful and I thought his only chance
was Queen D5 and G5 but here I was
confident I'm never in danger right
again like the king is cut the queen is
remains to protection like there's
scenarios where I even play Knight X G5
which is a huge blender and maybe it's
not as lost as it looks yeah not
okay it is but
um
but then you played A5 and
yeah I saw this
and apparently
whoa
okay but this is tough yeah it's very
tough especially with the time that he
had remaining and the trajectory the
game too
this is really tough that's very hard
yeah yeah study uh so that means here I
should have gone 96 of course uh which I
did just move later and after Queen C2
so the point is if I go Queen G80 which
is what I want there's G5
and while it's still winning but this
was that was the idea to bring the queen
back right so but after 96 Quincy tuna
28 and queen doesn't go and it's over
yeah you've had a couple of close calls
here so far in the rapid but the points
keep piling up how do you feel about
your performance so far uh it's all
right of course I I had one big Miss
against our USA but at the same time I
was much worse right uh for the world
game basically so you know I feel like
I'm defending very toughly
um still need maybe to put the nail you
know in the right place in some of the
games but plus two is very distant
square and this thing is uh Jordan is
piling up the points yeah tell me about
Jordan you think that he's in shape well
it's definitely in shape in even better
Shades than I predicted and I predicted
him that he was gonna do well so so far
I've been his lucky charm I guess
absolutely well hopefully you're your
own lucky charm and the rest of the
tournament plus do a very good score so
far Maxine hopefully you accumulate more
Point throughout the rest of the day
guys Maxima Sherlock with a big win here
in round seven over chakra modiaro thank
you
[Music]
Alejandro but here through the magic of
Television we see Magnus almost plot
flagging as he gets down to one second
and then playing this losing movement
wow and he did it almost in Jeffrey
Zhang's style of this Elon easy easy
move but F4 bad move and here's our
current standings after seven rounds
again so Ali Reza is fight with Jordan
Von Forest on 10 points Wesley
MBL wins and catches up with Wesley so
that's the big change and Madness clear
fifth position over 50 alone yeah and
once again nepo slipping down the
standings
commentator's curse and uh what's our
special at Q Boutique today
is chastity
you'd be surprised but pay attention to
the screen it's a chess set yes believe
it or not beautiful yeah lucky boxwood
chest man glossy 16 inch inch black and
white board handcrafted in Italy nice
yeah and his position is interesting
isn't it yeah a lacquered uh uh pieces
uh yeah this looks like uh from a perk
defense the famous Gary kasparo vessel
and topolov 1999 by gonze but a nice set
available at Q Boutique uh have a shop
take a look and as we go on a break we
asked our players well they their views
of the recently concluded candidates
tournament was here are their answers
we'll see on the other side of the break
around
the candidates just finished what was
your top takeaway from the tournament
it went like I expected except for the
winner because for some reason because I
just don't know so well neponia I don't
know him so well and I didn't really
expect him to repeat I believed that it
was very difficult to win two times in a
row basically Jan rolled away with it it
was impressive to watch he took care of
his chances and prevailed deservedly he
can run off with the tournament I was
following it at the beginning but then
he just started to win game after game I
would say
it was kind of unexpected because he won
the previous candidates and
usually it's hard to to win it twice in
a row I took my bet was Fabiano was
going to win it and the Americans both
played decently
but it wasn't enough there's only one
winner in the candidates as we can see
yes there was a lot of
opposite ups and downs and the
tournament was very tough and I took a
lot of experience there and yeah it was
a very good tournament for me because
all the players were experienced and I
managed to get a lot of experience there
so but it was a very interesting uh the
tournament I think the players were
playing
very aggressively not like in previous
years everyone was trying to win with
with both pieces and there was a lot of
interesting openings and ideas actually
not many not many berlins or some some
other solid openings so I think Jan is
in very good shape so that he's winning
is not that surprising but still he has
a very good chances in the match
it was it was great to see Yan in such a
good shape I think it's not very common
to to to have a player dominate the
field in in the candidates uh like that
because usually it's uh it's some uh
tremendous fight and some some players
who are not doing very well in the first
half they usually get back in the second
half and they produce some upsets and it
wasn't the case like Ian was really
Untouchable personally I would have
liked to see a little bit more from
alireza firusha since I really like his
playing style and I think he has it or
he might be
the next world champion at some point at
least but he didn't do so well here but
I'm sure we'll do a well when he gets a
large chance a young played with
fantastic strong tournament and he
deserved to play again against Magnus in
match I wish him all the best in the
match I hope
uh here Magnus will play much and we
will see a good match it was a great
experience and
I mean maybe I would say emotionally it
wasn't as
as much uh as it was one year ago
because you know
probably on you know in some way only
the first time counts but yeah I'm
sincerely proud of of my team who did
tremendous work to to help me and yeah
I'm really glad so I managed to please
my friends the candidates sort of
reaffirmed my my own experience from
nine years ago that's really really
tough I think in order to
to win the the tournament to yeah a lot
of things have to
have to go right
um or you have to get a little bit lucky
like I did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back to our live coverage of
the Croatia Zagreb rapid and Blitz Grand
Chester tournament we are ready for
round eight and here are our pairings
mural uh yeah it was players taken since
we have to be fast with this one exactly
two games we are watching closer than
the other ones
Carlson Against One Forest One Forest
being the leader not Carlson and then
for Rouge are facing Wesley so that's an
aggressive uh that's a big Clash so two
Marquee matchups we'll start with the
Magnus Carlson versus Jordan Ben forest
and as they say they're off
we have an English on the on board c2c4
a small surprise as Jordan stopped
we say Jordy by the way in Holland Jordy
stopped
E5 yeah I can imagine those two analyzed
whoa
D5 he takes what's that okay this is a
reverse Sicilian
where of all people Magnus himself has
been re playing these uh early Queen
takes D4 a white as I Said So the plan
is to go what Knight C6 and queen D7 as
is yeah yeah
I can't believe it Christian is Queen is
D5 Queen d8 wait but what's what's that
so basically are you losing Tempe oh
wait a second Magnus Magnus played this
quite a few times Queen takes D5 with
black yes all right I mean let's not
forget Guys these players work together
extensively and during the preparation
for a world championship match they know
their repertoires well especially Jordan
knows magnus's repertoire in and out
so well nice little surprised by Jordan
I have to say a little awkward facing
your own stuff I mean if Magnus has
played this D5 and queen d8
um for me this is new I and I played
English my whole career nobody gave me
all of these Tempe usually this night on
F6 if I ever got this position with
white it was because there was a night
on B6 yeah so it looked weird Queen
capturing the pawn on D5 and so on but
we ended up in a position that if black
would play quarter quote normal English
opening just drop the Knight on F6
instead of B6 yeah which perhaps
supposed to have some drawbacks but I'm
not aware exactly uh right now yes sir
did you ever play uh coach noi after you
seconded him oh many times uh in the
candidates how was the atmosphere and
the dynamic
um very very cordial uh for some strange
reasons uh Victor really just liked me
and we always got along even as we were
Rivals over the chessboard Victor had
some very very sharp words for almost
every one of my colleagues and I felt
like a teacher's pet you know you know
look at the nice Yasser you can say how
about the opening battle how did that by
that time because he knew his repertoire
right but we had kind of split so like
we both had different ideas and we
didn't use a lot of the ideas that we pl
that we prepared for against one another
it was sort of like
an unspoken rule that we didn't play
um into those lines there were so many
others so you did have this unspoken
rule exactly it was an unspoken rule
though and this is one of the reasons
why I think the move Knight F6
um is frowned upon as opposed to Knight
to B6 like right here if we go back and
if this Knight is on B6 we're in
standard territory but because the
Knight is on F6 it allows the move
Knight G5
and essentially I'm trading the B2 Pawn
for the E5 pawn and according to our
rule of centralization uh centralize
your pieces control the center I've made
a good trade for white now is that true
Miro yeah that's that's a big question
right I mean on the other hand if we
clearly I mean this type of positions if
black is on time to Castle you know
somehow developed and you have two very
nice files for the Rooks like rookonia
Rook on d8 if we can visualize that
somehow that's very nice and that would
be very comfortable setup for Black
right but on the other hand you know you
have your files I have my diagonals yeah
absolutely it's a battle of Chess ideas
here
uh
I've been told that b2b4 is novel E4 E4
it was no E4 it was E4 yeah it was novel
against the beef okay that that for me
is always a very strange decision A2 A3
I I'm thinking that the bishop actually
is not very well placed on B4 I mean I
want to play Bishop B2 Rook C1 take that
Knight and somehow take advantage Queen
A1 yeah take advantage of that Bishop on
B4 but he has played a2a3 uh did Magnus
uh kicking the bishop at once why did he
do that well well he did that I think
and he didn't play Bishop to B2 first is
that if you go Bishop B2 first then I
have to move Rook to E8 and now that
gives me an extra Square to get my
Bishop back to f8 once you attack it
with A3 and I think that's a better
replacement for the bishop because on E7
after A3 we expect Bishop to E7 unless
you want to give up the bishop pair or
the C5 Square then you don't have this
fa square and if you go to E7 Bishop B2
Rook to E8 then you have to lose another
Tempo to put some pressure on the E file
so I think it's just
um a way to win one extra Tempo in the
position
and Magnus still with 25 minutes on the
clock he definitely knows what he's
doing in this one he's been it's
certainly playing it very very quickly I
hear you loud and clear what you're
saying there about the inclusion of the
move a2a3
I'm still not all together
convinced that this is uh We've gained a
Tempo it's not exactly that we've got in
a temple right because we did not have
an opportunity to play a comfortable
move a random move yeah we spend the
tempo on 8283 so it's basically getting
the same setup with the bishop and fate
eventually black decides to go so high
the difference was was not forced to
move at any point right oh yeah I think
you will have to drop it to fa yeah
otherwise that Rook on E8 is useless
also I think the pawn on A3 is actually
an asset because imagine a queen
potentially coming to C2 Knight to B4 is
no longer on the board even after the
move that you showed E3 Knight to B4 and
ideas to jump to B3 to D3 are not on the
board so I I think A3 actually helps why
we do have the sequence that we expected
by the way uh the bishop dropped back to
E7 as opposed to a A5 and then to B6
Rook went to E8 where he expects
something like Rook C1 and or E2 E3 just
your quick take Mira that you know you
you see this uh dare I say it dragon
pawn structure if I play the move D2 D3
I have uh five and one versus three and
three which structure do you prefer once
again like being
for well considerable part of my career
like reti and the English player myself
I really like White's position white
setup in terms of structure and so on
yeah but there have been quite a few
people who proved me wrong
the answer you know the answer is always
I don't know I really I mean it depends
yeah if you force me to pick the side
I'm playing wide dude yeah that's clear
but definitely why for me as well for me
uh I'm also a dragon player I play
Dragon quite a lot a lot of my career
I know
I know I actually had very decent
results with with the dragon because
back in those days I used to repeat my
uh my theory so that really helped also
the engines weren't as strong and that
gave me a little bit of a wiggle room
all right we'll definitely keep an eye
on the developments of this uh Magnus
versus uh Jordan then Forest but we
actually had two really Marquee matchups
coming into this round and unfortunately
for us and the game between ferrugia and
Wesley I'm seeing a very dry position
there yeah
did they come out of Berlin it sure did
rookie won this one is dry and ferrugia
offered this Pawn sacrifice Magnus said
nothing doing I'm not a taker
and well we even have like pair of
Bishops for black right right I mean
this was a intriguing decision for me uh
to force the Knight coming to F5 like I
really want to play on these dark
squares and I'm going to try to prove
that my knight is superior to that light
squared uh Bishop
strategic nuances here but I've seen
Wesley neutralize the best players in
the world from such positions I don't
think he's going to have trouble holding
this
maybe something else to look at shall we
go to the where is Shaq Shaq is always
good fun I I recommend the game between
topalov and Ivan sarich ah at the very
top because uh topology just sacrificed
me wow whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
mean there's a lot of stuff has happened
yeah right it's like it's it's an idol
third night again with Knight on F3
right and very very straightforward
stuff yeah well it takes D4 and E5 and
by the way this is still Theory
great stuff and what does theory
prescribe Castle
or Knight of C6 these are the two main
moves in the position
he Castle okay and now topalov needs to
know the next move that's not it yes I
think Bishop six and six we might have
trouble right of all these uh you're
saying here Queen H3 H3 is the main move
in H3 and in fact the only one that
keeps the balance in the position if you
do take on F6 black is already better
gotcha quick wage three at the same time
it gives white I have to say some
initiative because then black has to
know the theory as well and it's not
that easy you have to play the move H6
right now Knight takes C6 allow the move
Knight takes E6 with extreme
complications in the position so let's
wait and see uh whether topalov is well
prepared whether he remembers his theory
definitely seems by the time spent up to
this point that sarich is still within
historetical knowledge uh he hasn't
spent as much time and topology just
sacrificed the piece so unless he was
completely surprised that he would have
thought for a little bit he's not so I
think he's still with the historical
knowledge we're expecting to move Queen
H3 this is one thing also Miro I want to
say I really do respect these players
who have been in that and of the world
championship matches they have put in an
enormous amount of Labor into their
openings they know stuff that they
forgot that they knew it because they've
studied so much and they really
sometimes just show these old weapons
all of a sudden and you're just up the
line yeah and then yeah I felt it myself
a couple of times that like yeah the the
most uh kind of brutal example was me
playing against copper believe it or not
I believe it and it's yeah
you obviously played cup of uh many
times and I got the sudden chance in
some second Russian League whatever Club
Championship anyway I was brave enough
to play The King's Indian and he picked
some really rare system by that time
and later on okay I've lost the game the
long story short lost the game and later
on analyzing he said something like ah
we were considering this against Gary in
1980 whatever yeah
I just felt like an idiot 30 years later
something new to me you know yeah and
the guy said yeah we were analyzing like
you imagine him analyzing this on his
pocket uh yeah you know pocket chess set
in his in a train maybe and we're
beating you 30 years later we have a
Brotherhood in this because I remember
playing Anatolian Reykjavik and I was
playing uh this Catalan variation and he
made a very comfortable draw with black
pieces just very comfortable and even I
think he spent very little time and I
was like what is going on and he said
yes I I prepared this for Victor
cochinoy in my match in Baguio City yes
I felt like an idiot as well I just
walked into Christian what do you have
for us well I was still watching all of
the games that are developing right now
uh this one between mvl and nepo is
quite intriguing a lot of imbalances
especially in the structure this
position has not been seen up to this
point it seems like let's see where the
novelty was made all the way oh my
goodness all the way at move six no way
went to E7 yes in this position Knight
D4 Queen 27 was the novelty Knight to D2
was played beforehand but once again
nepo is showing his stuff he's showing
his preparation probably for the match
and this is where we are right now H3
and it does seem like nepo pretty much
has equalized maybe even more out of the
opening I'm seeing at a white structure
it does seem like white needs to get
something going on the king side
potentially get F4 but check that a
lifetime how close it is 10 wins for mvl
11 losses with 15 draws these players
are definitely very evenly matched and
this game is appointing exactly to that
fact yeah not exactly the domination
when we've been on those head-to-heads
where Magnus has been featured yeah well
it's not been very pretty for her Magnus
is a photo hero it's not exactly the
same yes so that it's relieving to have
somebody like really it's more or less
even school yeah and then realizing yeah
it's Magnus not involved in this kind of
head-to-head and Magnus is just taking
over against uh Jordan right now oh
really oh I think so uh okay we're I I
wanna yeah okay let's just go there
because again I did see that topolov had
Blake Queen H3 against Yvonne sarich and
H7 H6 came quickly let's jump into the
Magnus Carlson game uh Knight C5 this is
kind of what I wanted uh put by Pawn on
D4 and frankly if I play Rook in E1 and
E4 it's resigns
hanging yeah uh yeah for me rookie one
E4 D5 is it's gone uh and you just don't
survive this Avalanche that's going
through the sentence
that's the problem you you don't have a
lot oh you you've probably missed the
moment already right with but something
was to be had to be done maybe you have
to take on C5 and try to go 97 bail out
with C6 or something along those lines
yeah Bishop Knight takes B7 and Bishop
takes C6 doesn't work because B2 form is
hanging but always you think that those
types of tactics
are in the air
this looks awful and maybe let's go to
E7 try to play C6
here you know
there's going to be some problems on it
oh
horrendous no no no this does look like
positional domination again I love these
theoretical battles let me just again I
want to check on this topolov game
because
he did play H6 this whole Queen H3 H6
Miro do you have any experience with
this no not at all uh okay Christian is
still a theory apparently yeah I know
everybody still five games
C6 is the best move and Then followed by
uh Knight to C6 Knight C6 is what black
plays then you what capture is it time
to start grabbing capture on F6 you take
back with the Rook Knight takes D4 and
we get into some sort of an end game ah
so that's an end game we are talking
about yeah
it seems like black is slightly better
oh sorry white is slightly better but uh
not much
Rook F2 Knight D4 okay uh faruja Wesley
so Knight E5 uh slow play by whom Miro
who Mighty five minutes six and
whites to move
way to move here yeah you can you can
maybe push the queen backwards with
Bishop F4 yeah but you I'm just I'm just
thinking like how serious is this as an
attempt to play for an advantage
no I I feel
absolutely comfortable I would say if I
was in black shoes here that with four
with a semi-closed position of 14 pawns
on the board
One open file
left polygi FC's book Grand Master
preparation for me was an absolutely
wonderful book and he in that book for
me introduced the term The Chopping
Block
so the open file is where the Rooks came
and they were chopped off
so you you play rookie eight and it's
the chopping block everything gets
traded and black is is happy I don't see
Wesley uh having trouble and Magnus is
uh in no a mood to wait right now
wow for Bishop G6 maybe F4 dang he he's
coming after your right now okay this is
the time that you've got to start uh
looking for sacrifices
B6 is uh I'm thinking it's forced so
dude six night day six yes and sacrifice
The Exchange and be happy that you got a
pawn for it
his death I'm I'm a little surprised for
me the move F4 is surprising I think
rookie one would have been my choice but
F4 is the world champion is yes
but if it's good it's good I mean if
it's good it's good but B6 B6 96 so once
again how do we do it B6 has to be
played right absolutely if you don't do
it you just get crushed
Avalanche is coming
exactly
so but we take on
e4 yeah
you you can decide uh in what later
order I I'll go with the flow
you want to take a B8 now otherwise the
Knight is actually pathetic I mean uh
yeah okay perhaps you can actually start
wait just one second perhaps you can uh
start with Queen to C2 or queen to D3
okay I will drop back my Rook to 37.
okay so let's start with Queen C2 just
because it's supposed to put some
pressure on a C7 and maybe stops me for
whatever reasons for playing Bishop to
D6 and now it's time finally capture the
rook and uh and yeah I definitely uh
like the extra material but still the
pawn on F4 means the king is a little
bit exposed that's why I'm trying to
exchange all the reasons as fast as
possible C3 Knight C4 yeah you have some
let's go rookie one
it's
it's not beautiful
it's not beautiful uh
that it's what black has to do
absolutely there's just no choice I mean
uh let's let's just I'm going to refresh
my board and go to the current position
but after F4 if you do anything of this
nature uh Bishop C5 Rook C5 B6 how about
that
B6 yeah a rookie five rookie rookie yes
I just wanted to say that this the this
Pawn on e4 needs protection yeah but
then I take I was thinking Knight C4
first or taken Knights
uh there might be some yeah maybe 94
first again I feel like these types of
opportunities
suggest to me at least that F4
is
premature uh and also excuse me but I I
don't think after B6 I have Rook D5 Rook
David Phi I think we missed that and
it's just ah rookie five yeah and
everything clarifies because of five is
the next move
that's rather painful yeah that's why
that's very good yeah uh okay then I'm
backing up on this one yeah not have to
have to play B6 have to have to go 46. I
agree it's taking a lot of time for a
decision that we kind of think is forced
but it's something but he did I think he
did
while Jordan on on bottom 15. we we have
a lot of Legends in the barbaric
Northwest where I'm from and one of my
uh favorites
um Dr elad mashkovski
he was very famous for saying same move
faster was better
uh B7 B6 took Jordan a little time how
much time does he have remaining 11
minutes and Magnus seemingly twice as
much 20 20 to 21 minutes and Jordan
recognizing that he had no choice B7 B6
he could not
wait for white to spank F5 into the
position and he did sacrifice exchange
we haven't said that this very often uh
this tournament but nepo is uh cruising
right now whoa against mvo really that's
a huge game because mvl is actually
right up there with our tournament
leaders and
and we have a result already Miro yeah
I'm Groff makes a draw again
yeah we did not pay too much attention I
would apologies to the players uh uh
well well that was that was you know
just like straight from the opening
they've swapped everything inside of a
hacking contest there uh what's going on
uh why did you say nepo is cruising
Queen to B8 which was played I have to
play F4 I assume and then just rookie
eight
after F four D two EA
your king is so exposed
it it doesn't make a happy
look does it on this diag oops excuse me
this diagonal and in fact if you do go
Queen to F3 right now yes some Knights
Knight to D4
that looks very popular
by the way this bishop on one is making
a great impression I know uh uh maybe it
means F4 is simply wrong and I actually
have to swallow my pride and play a move
like King
G1 the same
that's kind of saying D to E8 and
apparently the queen is stranded you
don't have good squares for the queen
right don't I feel it
yeah but even 93 and some Queen G3
I'm afraid will be I think
94.95 as well 94 then F3 might be if you
take on A6 Knight takes F3 oh yes okay
well that's an explanation hold on 94
Rook takes E8 what what happened there
so I guess let's take only one first ah
no we're talking
E1 Rook takes E1 yeah
I think you could decide if you would
prefer your queen on A7 or not my king
could be on H2
um by the way King G1 uh Maxine uh
understanding
um he has done something seriously wrong
uh checking in on uh farusha versus
Wesley
well let's see we did have 95 Queen D6
Queen F4
E7
okay
G4 Bishop E6 rookie one rookie eight
Queen F3 what you said he wants F6 and
he any trades would have been welcome
and it still feels like F6 is
the move the move
um
is you know safe now safe is one thing I
wonder if at some point actually have
some intentions exactly this partner G4
two Bishops after all and you know
like let me just put a move on the board
for a second and so you get some
position like this where you're
committed yourself to age three uh you
always have to you know don't worry
about G5 at least
did I uh end up stranding my own Bishop
in the enemy encampment
um okay that game such an important game
for our standing I think right now it
does feel like alireza especially due to
the time management as well he should
probably try to pull the brakes and make
a draw he did play Knight D3 as well uh
explain Bishop to F4 follow it with
Knight to C5 try to force that exchange
get the opposite color of Bishops and
call it the day
all right I will keep that one Magnus
Carlson uh are we feeling that the move
F4 was mistimed or is it or do we still
like his material plus yeah well it's
it's an extra exchange right exchanges
and exchange she six was played by
Jordan okay on a good day if Jordan
could ever establish a knight on C4 he
does after all have a pawn for the
exchange he needs a knight anchored on
C4 why do I like the Knight on C4 well
the Knight on C4 would actually be
hitting uh A3 and B2 sorry like Queen D5
is another tempting these kinds of
fortress-like moves yeah
so how do we improve the position for
white right now
at some point it just feels like you
probably want to go D5 right no question
about it well maybe day before I mean if
anything
maybe a 40 stop B5 yeah that's a move
that's definitely a move yeah so let's
go let's make a few moves A4 I go Queen
D5 yeah A4 Queen D5 and I'm yet to yet
to find a way I like by the way I think
we have Queen two F Queen to F3 okay so
stopping Queen D5 also perhaps getting
ready to play the move D5
Queen
F3 inviting B5 B5 yeah and then the
question is how we go about this one
I suppose C6 is an issue right so that
are we in time to play Bishop
yeah but which C3 uh you mean Knight C4
is awkward to play I don't know if it is
or not I might be just simply trading
off the A3 bond for the C6 pawn queen F3
on the board B5 is a a challenging move
but then the other question is what have
I what am I doing if I don't
play
um before B5 I'm a little bit
worried that after A4 Bishop C3 I won't
get a chance yeah absolutely there won't
be other opportunity yeah and maybe even
this Rook
uh along the e-file at times so let's
just play age six
um times nine minutes for Jordan I think
around 18 or 19 minutes for Magnus okay
that's white Splat here
okay let's say I play A4 just B5 is on
the board by the way okay I thought that
was the most critical move
that uh yeah that Jordan needed to uh
played
to plant his flag if you will on the C4
square and say this square is mine okay
so hang on so now Bishop C3 you said but
how about Bishop C3 Bishop takes a three
one takes a five right they should pay
five I was afraid Queen D4 and taking
the Rook might not be oh okay that's
nice I like all of a sudden yeah yeah
hurting the feelings there that is a
nice one okay
but at the same time yeah like okay one
there is before and it's crazy like all
black pieces are awkwardly placed
each other yeah uh they hang together
so what if I try to go to E1 yeah T1 for
E8 but then you go Bishop f8
well it just doesn't this seem like this
is the right direction for a while right
I don't know uh you you might be onto
something here Christian takes takes
rookie eight this is going to be
uh we're gonna take another Pawn
ah check let's go that's interesting
yeah checking G2 you pick up the full D4
as well Queen takes C6 capture this one
and
well this is I think more or less an
ideal for both players if uh if I know
my Peter's Fiddler very well he would
say in the grunfeld those two pawns on
the queen side uh with a bishop are
worth an exchange current position Miro
uh Queen is oops no that wasn't it
that's analysis let me just shake that
off and replay the current position
it's not easy right no no that's that's
not easy anymore for a wife
and this is the problem for Magnus at
least in this tournament he got great
positions but he had some problems with
conversion clear we've seen that uh
against Wesley we've seen it against
Apollo as well he managed to win that
one but he had some difficulties and
with Wesley he he made a move with one
second honestly five is on the board
guys D5 okay
um D5 do we trust D5 all kinds of
applauses and gold coins for
understanding opening up the bishop and
everything else but we do all of this
when we kind of say we don't know what
we're talking about is it cool and you
know I guess Rook D1 or uh simply go for
it we could we could also think of
playing Knight C4 first for whatever
reason I don't know
might might have been interesting but
yeah for now let's just I I was gonna uh
kind of uh play for nights yeah but then
maybe the difference is that I can take
Rook D5 and I have Bishop D4 if it's a
check on B6 so the problem with Knight
C4 if you start with the move Knight to
C4
yes I I do have a feeling that I might
be able to take on C6 I was uh sorry if
I excuse me D5 I wanted to take yes
right but if I think Mira wanted to go
Knight to 64.9 C4 and then you just take
off yeah you can take no no nc6 yes
for some reason I was only looking at
Rook takes and then take on
c65 and I'm getting on d8 very fast yeah
yeah I mean queen C8 is certainly not
what you want to do well I don't know
because any Queen d8 could be met by
Queen e6s so just to put just to put it
on the board again I suspect I'm losing
but then I hide on H3 right
I hide with my king on H3 so I get the
second Queen you give me a few checks
and then I go to H3 Aha and and you're
you're threatening made on f8 uh very
very good
by the way guys it does seem like mvl is
just about to resign seriously yes
my man
is it his first win yes
well I mean nepo is an absolutely
outstanding Blitz and Rapid player we
are used to see him him on the podium
never mind in the wallowing at the at
the
bottom half so first win came after
round
eight just something like that yeah
shocking yeah really really shocking was
that the final position by the way yeah
Knight on F2 is going to give him a
Checkmate Checkmate on the very next
Queen H2 coming yeah
I that is a very pretty pattern yeah
Queen HD uh
uh
uh not that I can remember any of my I
mean I've getting made it and given mate
and stuff like that but well that's a
very nice thing with an adventurous King
on H4 a good a good General should
always lead his army into battle okay uh
Magnus uh back to Magnus because he did
play uh the Jordan because here I was
having some very doubtful
Queen A5
I'm kind of tickling downstairs and I'm
looking at this a pawn with uh wait a
second not only is that and with large
eyes there's also some Queen A8 and this
then it's not supposed to work but just
that this is a little oh it's still
hanging B2 is on tap A3 do I have Bishop
take no sorry Bishop takes G7 I wish I
could G7 and then Rook d8 yeah discovery
check unfortunately discover check
doesn't really work black has a threat
which is Knight E3 but you probably kill
Bishop C1 and stock somehow Miracle uh
Miracles the bishop on
b285 yes to be honest yes just to
mention that Queen A8 is an alternative
but right uh Queen A5
the immediate check just runs
individually but it's not the end of the
story and maybe then you pin right by
the way it's maybe when you pain and
then it's it's chocolate right so once
again check forces official and then
somebody seven or C6 yeah that's a very
shaky yeah I know especially because
again A3 is hanging uh Queen E7 Queen E7
okay there was there was quite a number
of Alternatives here yeah but that's one
is interesting as well so did you choose
the right Square though it does seem
like uh it shows uh the wrong Square A5
B6 yes but no the ones that we discussed
were actually the best ones the best
ones was a C7
oval which is a bit uh
something right we haven't even
considered wow I that was not on my
radar uh
E7 why is okay first of all Mira why did
he put his Queen on E7 what was
attractive about this the same reasoning
why you were putting the queen on iPhone
yeah exactly from a practical
perspective I do like this move Queen to
E7 and I have to say Magnus responded
very well with Bishop D4 Bishop to D4
yes inviting Queenie one check not
Bishop to C3 which would have defended
against Queen 31 but after Queen to A3
then unfortunately I think black would
have been back in the game unfortunately
for Magnus Bishop to D4 is a really good
move really good move yes
okay if I if I just play it again on E1
and now we have King G2 on the board
Okay g is there I was a little reluctant
to give up
troll over the door so quickly
but uh let's pause our analysis and jump
to Zagreb as Alejandro is with our
winner nepo
we're here with
it's been a tough tournament so far
finally a nice Victory here against
Maxine by Sherlock perhaps a little
shaky at the beginning what's going on
oh well it's surely not my best
tournament like
uh so I'm just basically struggling
every day and it's um yeah maybe just
simply not enough energy but uh yeah and
this last game shouldn't you know
deceive in that sense do you mean that
you're still not feeling in shape oh
I mean if there is like an antonym to
the world of the shape that's that's my
case
well still a nice Victory against Maxim
tell us what happened exactly in today's
game it felt the opening was shaky but
then you took over well I was lost after
seven moves I could resign but then he
didn't play C4 in the truth like
quite playable then yeah I think C5 is
nothing more but I think there's 97 or
something is is the move as far as I
remember but okay of course like
uh uh I wasn't like quite enough to
repeat any lines so I also mixed up
things badly against the E1 in there in
the first game so yeah I'm just the
internet has been wondering has the
announcement made you a bit upset is it
going through your mind uh no I would
say it affected but I don't think it
just affected that much so I lost you
know all my skills yeah immediately in
one moment I guess it's just yeah
sometimes you know you go with the flow
yeah it's to wrap it in this tournament
so so far flow is against me but maybe
this game I would change something I
hope so you still have two more games
here in the rapid one more game Sorry in
the rapid perhaps a strong finish will
give you good moves for the Blitz
I hope so well yeah here with a victory
with the black pieces against mvl thank
you Alejandro uh thank you nepo
he didn't seem happy that's but let's
put it mildly uh jumping back into our
around farrugia versus Wesley I dare say
absolutely nothing has happened Wesley
is keeping uh jumping back to Magnus
versus uh Jordan van Forest after Queen
E1 check King G2 during that interview I
expected something to have happened
nothing happened
why not he kept thinking and he went all
the way back to E8 with the queen I
guess I mean he made some very long live
yeah Queen E8 protecting the pawn but
was it really that's confusing I I
thought it was strange right here to
give up control over the d8 square after
Bishop D4 I expected A6 just picking a
move for example but he played well it
looks like a waste of time frankly I
mean and that's why he spent so much
time on it he had to realize that
unfortunately Rook to d8 is just coming
with devastating consequences right
right now there is no Perpetual that
King is perfectly placed on G2 yeah
offended by the queen and the potential
Bishop coming to F2 so you have to
defend the two subscribe Bishop F2 was
uh
actually yeah uh Queenie eight but this
actually we might want to show that if
Queen to D2 don't play Bishop that's a
beautiful one yeah Queen because of
Knight to E3 [ __ ] H3 that's quite so
you have to go King H3 right that is uh
very nice and you win back your exchange
with a winning game but after King H3 uh
all of the fireworks
are finished suddenly Rook d8 as well as
a bishop Discovery is on the board and
we have quickly Bishop takes A7 after
this queen A8 move and Bishop takes A3
takes A3 so that's extra exchange
um the Knight is still safely anchored
for the time being but whenever you see
The Rook you're always afraid that white
will majestically get to D.A yeah
but it's not that easy to do it uh how
will he do it well some Queen D3 to
start with and perhaps some forcing
Bishop E7 and
I wasn't I was being a little bit maybe
too aggressive I was looking okay
if I if I could be so green no no no but
Queen B3 yeah
Queen E4 check you always have that's
correct at least at least apologies that
I think is a very nice safe move well it
preps uh the the queen uh leaving the
vicinity you know something like queen
and the bishop goes back
okay so only one Pawn in a night but
again the Knight is safely anchored the
black king is safe and thanks to the
fact that there's a Pawn on F4 White's
King is a little bit exposed a little
bit a little bit three Queen D3 getting
ready to go Rook to d8 okay yeah d8 is
uh we had serious should should we be
let's say our our most annoying best I
think it's time yeah because now King to
H3 is met with Queen twitch but King G1
now right so yeah so you don't have
checks on the first ring so King G1 and
I'm probably making it to d8 unless
Knight D6 is what you're playing
and by the way there is a huge
discrepancy on clock right now only two
minutes for Jordan and 15 minutes for
Magnus very very different from his last
game against Wesley so where the world
champion left himself I kid you not
folks with a single second on his clock
to make his move which he success he
didn't doing and that game ended in a
draw but boy I tell you we were on our
edge of our seats I mean uh you know and
we do have Queen A8 not Queen C6 but
Queen a the difference is that from A8
we can go to A1 in case of King G1 on
the sixth ranks and now we got where's
White we probably prefer King H3 ah
right so that that's you you're getting
access to only one of the one of the two
it's other H6 or A1 right so then if you
go Queen to C8 cover it up with F5 right
yes
and queen A8 on the board but that's a
huge difference on the clock times I
must say 15 minutes to two minutes just
to repeat what I heard right now 15
minutes but yes huge difference
okay Magnus by the way Magnus with us
with a seven out of seven rounds means
he's on fifty percent going into this uh
game and we do have King H3 on the board
I mean we've been saying that he's not
in good shape yeah yeah he said that but
he's still with him striking rage right
yeah absolutely and he's more like those
guys yeah right who can win the blitz
with like huge humongous score
uh but 18 games in the blitz of course
18 points will be up for grab this
weekend we talked about that too when
Gary was world champion you know like
when Gary was having a a bad result or
something of this nature you know poor
guy was in second place or Thursday yeah
like on a on a terrible plus three score
and I'll say if you check uh Carlson's
rating performances like a terrible
tournament means played of 27-80 yeah he
does it you know so bad so bad by his
standards I I was I did a commentary
with Peter Laker with something just
exactly like that happened
we were both very aggressive about
magnus's terrible for performance and
somebody in chat said yeah but it's
2800.
a terrible for form it's a 2800. instead
of the checks are done F5 Jordan needs
to find a way to continue this game
because the B5 Pony okay you have to do
something about that
you have to decide is even more
threatening it feels like but I one of
the reasons why I actually like Queen C6
as opposed to Queen A8 is I thought
that the night
strangely enough might be able to block
the default the problem is whenever you
go Knight D6 in almost not in this
scenario because that will just take I
have Bishop C5 very often yes and that
kicks the night away from these six yes
so just to repeat what well just a
second uh in this moment when when
Jordan played Queen A8 he could have
played Queen C6 and against King G1
1966
Bishop to C5 Jordan getting down to his
last minute guys oh
but if you can't find a move I mean what
can he do right
well again how bad is it if I make a
move before
like before before
it wins the problem with B4 is no
I can just go uh Bishop C5 Rook f8 yeah
oh my goodness
seven he Parts with his B5 Pawn but
that's that's game over that's sad news
uh fun facts
Magnus has not won a game since get this
are you ready for this round two round
two
and the Vaseline was being victimized in
day one and that was his when Magnus has
win against vessel in touch beloved by
the way was also shaky at some point yes
right we've identified here said that
not together well he gets the advantage
and something very uncharacteristic I
would say he gets the advantage he
cannot convert it exactly then that is
very uncharacteristic for Magnus we're
looking at Rook takes B5 it's a whole
Exchange
um King is a little bit weird on H3 but
the material
Jordan knows that it's bad so but how
about worried about why is he not just
simply snapping that pawn off the board
is he trying to find something better or
after Bishop E7 he's he has to be
thinking about Bishop C5 but Bishop C5
Bishop F6 and I don't see a clear
continuation after that
exactly uh I'm thinking he's thinking
Bishop C5 Bishop F6 Bishop D4 and is the
bishop better placed on F2 or D4 when I
play the move Rook Taylor
yeah but he finally hit them with
hesitation Rook takes B5
and H5 H5 let's go so at least no back
rank
issues for now we're going down to his
last 33 seconds sorry I'm not a big fan
of this move H5 by the way uh feels like
Pawn is actually weaker on age five when
it is on for example H6
um how about how about Bishop A7 and he
had a caveman approach I mean I want to
play rugby
you're not very subtle
no no no no no no no rewards for
subtlety but sometimes you know uh
brutality does hit its Mark I guess I
have to go Bishop Bishop D6 maybe yeah
that what keeps you afloat because
otherwise yeah it's Rook d8 with a check
and then followed by F6 check would just
wear prior to the move Rook takes B5 I
was louding the fact that the Knight was
anchored yeah once we get here uh the
knight's not anchored I start thinking
of trying to dominate the knight in
other words if you could play Knight D6
98 Knight F6 maybe you'll be pleased
with yourself
I I appreciate what you're saying yeah
but just go back to D5 yeah going back
to D5 making sure the Knight remains
in the air uh would Lazy Man's chance
yeah 55c is a very nice movie by the way
you're too challenging you're
threatening Bishop C5 after that and
then if Bishop takes you take the Knight
win the bishop on a pin right yeah Rook
D5 is very good yeah
and Rook D5 also from a practical
perspective it just feels like you're
asking so many questions and so many
hidden questions for your opponent
Bishop to A7 at least you give your
opponent one more move gain another 10
seconds because there's no other
alternative but Bishop to D6
I like room T5 Christian every time I go
to look at the game of Wesley so I see
not not much has happened not much has
happened let's not forget we have the
Paulo's game as well
it's also quite interesting but this one
I think is is the key one right now and
Rook D5 when we think Magnus is going to
just
whoa okay whoa if you're gonna go down
you want to go down in a blaze of glory
look at this uh Jordan was waiting for
Rook D5 by the way best movie in the
position apparently yeah well G5
certainly a find because now G4 pushes
the king back into this sort of a box
where everybody is getting checked
Magnus was going to play G4 I didn't
want to go I didn't want to get pushed
back into yeah that little box you were
mentioning but how about G4 for Magnus
you know a good General leads his King
into battle
[Laughter]
there were also the other thing I do
like about the move G4 for Magnus is it
does somehow if I ever get my Bishop to
G3 I take away two very important
squares for this night this Knight
remains stranded on the queen side
you're playing a a rook down yeah
eventually it's gonna gonna be lost
right right I'm expecting G4 but uh
Kristen jump in with your take on the
position let's see what the game
now one thing about this position that
you don't want to see as white and this
is why Magnus needs to keep the tempo up
is play against the Knight The Very
jumpy night with a weak King with only a
few seconds on the clock so that's why I
think Magnus really needs to find
something now and he needs to keep the
tempo keep the pressure on his opponent
right now don't go down on time like you
did in the game against Wesley the king
G2 sets up uh Miro at yeah 2c6 which is
on the board you were recommending
Bishop C5 a moment before this queen
lands on C6 which has just happened 26
and the is Queen E4 any good Queen E4 is
a move yeah and and then that obviously
threatens The Rook to d8 so you have to
do something
it's funny how the queen was on E8 yeah
it went to A8 it could have gone to C6
immediately right and defended the pawn
on B5 but yeah King G1 yeah Queen E4
apparently would have been met with
Knight D6 so King G1 okay sidestepping
the pin that's fine okay and also
stopping a a little night or Knight to
E5 as you say the pin the The Rook not
captured he's lost seconds 18 seconds he
made that last move with eight seconds
on the clock
not a good sign is it F6 F6 looks very
tempting very tempting and so okay what
if we just go for the kill with Rook to
D4 how is the how is the variation after
that
Knight to E5 I would assume right right
it takes D6
how is this this is it it must be
winning I don't believe that these
checks will ever you only have one check
and then I cover it with Queen D1 at the
end right yes exactly yeah
with six wins as well yeah it's funny I
didn't see Rook D4 but I sure did see F6
I mean I thought yes wrote the D4 yeah
and Magnus does play we're going to see
a resignation soon
Knight to B2
Rook takes d61 C1 F Queen F1 no no no
there is knight uh Queen F1 after Knight
B2 and Jordan saw that and after King H1
I think he resigns
King H1 it's important not to go to G2
and not to run into double check even
though you are probably still winning
but or maybe not Maybe not maybe and
there we have it as no this is Jordan's
second loss uh he started with two wins
and then had a loss uh but uh Magnus
takes down uh wins an important game I
have to just for the tournament
standings go to the game of Wesley so
nothing is going to happen in this one
this one is wild
whoa this one is completely Wild
yeah and there's been a couple of a
couple of changes in evaluation along
the ways the topolov was winning then he
made the mistake sarich was much better
guys but I look at the position and if I
don't know the rules of Chess I'm
everything is so splattered absolutely
it feels absolutely unfair like we have
in fairuzia's game we have an end game
for last 30 minutes maybe right and it's
a board full of pieces and they're all
over the place we look all over the
place exactly like Knight A5 like
somebody threw those pieces randomly on
the board right exactly exactly Queen to
B6 and the Knight on A5 is actually
protected by The Rook on the other side
of the board right one of the most
beautiful things about his book my 200
best games best Elise mislav is he
strive for harmony yeah this is chaos
this is ridiculous I've never seen such
you know profane pieces Rook H5 Rook d
985 Bishop A3 by the way that's a just
stay at the dark Pawn on detail I think
the pawn works as well yeah that's what
he took it done
and by the way 10 seconds for uh Yvonne
for Ivonne
queen queen takes G2
everything's protected you can take E6
Pawn if you like that's a nice hakasito
check
not only that but if you go into H7 then
I have ideas of Knight to F6 Knight to
essay oh Knight to S6 is also looking at
that one Knight to G3 ideas uh as well
but yeah this must be
26 should be Queen takes E6 should be uh
there's also there's also a hidden move
like Queen from A6 guards the Knight on
f2c you can take on D2 with the rook in
fact oh that might be like you know once
again lazy men's chess as yeah just like
swaps on pieces simply find a position
speaking of swapping pieces and
simplifying the position Queen E6 king
h8 a king queen
G4 wins as well yeah no questions asked
King C2
and let's jump to Zagreb as Alejandro is
with the world champion
we're here with world champion Magnus
Carlson he needed some points to really
challenge the leaders and that's what he
did he just beat a very clean game
against Jordan One Forest Magnus welcome
to the studio tell us this seemed very
clean
um yeah uh I think he
um misplayed the the opening or the
Early Middle game a little bit uh and
then he made a good decision to suck the
exchange that was I think
um that was I think the only chance a
little bit further right yeah
um so yeah for I mean B6 was good I mean
I'd kind of underestimated that because
I thought after I went to F4 I thought
I'd just I was just gonna roll over him
um
so after after that there was quite a
bit of quite a bit of work
um
but I felt that I was always
um favorite to to make it in the end and
absolutely it made it you made it seem
very simple especially with the huge
time Advantage you have the technique
was very strong yeah I mean for once I
actually played kind of quickly and the
two times that I played quickly against
Dominguez as well I actually um did did
well in that that game also so
um overall I think I've played okay
until I get in time travel and then I
just played horribly uh so my time
management hasn't been I wasn't good but
there there has been some some
improvements uh I mean I lost the game I
never in a million years should it
should have should have lost definitely
should have beaten Dominguez should
probably have had chances against so as
well so you know
um
it's not as bad as the score suggests I
feel like I'm playing myself into the
reasonable shape so I have one more game
and then a lot of a lot of Blitz to look
forward to absolutely we have tons of
Blitz ahead of us this course not that
bad now that you took that Jordan you're
still within Striking Distance of some
of the leaders yeah yeah I guess I'll uh
I'll be um two points behind dalareza
which is not good but it's not a
disaster so it's still pretty early yeah
we have one more rapid games and
remember 18 full rounds of Blitz well
we'll let you rest for the third round
of the day thank you Magnus guys back to
the studio two remaining games thank you
uh Alejandro one remaining game because
uh vessel in topolov Miro has one uh
trapped uh Yvonne's a queen on the queen
side with a king side with Rook H3 we
have this one a game remaining Wesley
trying to win this one like who's uh
yeah that's the best one what's going on
in this game because I thought we were
going to be witnessing a draw but as you
say who is playing
it must be Wesley there's no way alireza
is playing for a win this one that is a
good point Bishop H4 followed by King to
E2 probably would have been an offer for
a repetition he decided against it with
Bishop P5 one of the things when you
make a move like Bishop E5 you have to
always calculate these King upon endings
because
you've burnt your Bridges essentially
you know anytime you're getting into a
king upon end game there's no
turning back if you will King 32 King 3
6 King 123.
you want to be honest
finally a draw agreed uh as we can just
now take a brief Gander at the game of
topolo for just a second uh that final
move was actually pretty uh nasty one in
this position we have just left that
into my magnet f
F3 F4 is not as innocent as it appeared
Knight came back into play in case
that's a visual yeah but even threats
look if look it's like from a different
game the Bishops on C1 for some reason
yes just imagine what part of a game
there was exactly let's go maybe yeah
very strange looking position Christian
uh this game uh was Discord I mean I
don't know I very very rarely have I
seen such a a tangled web of pieces
let's go back before he takes on B7
is it equal material
uh yeah you see like like every move is
marked with other equation because they
were the engine
trouble creating a mess and that's what
I I mean look at this look at these
black pieces everywhere but for vessel
and topolov it wasn't the 3-0 score I
was predicting he started with three
losses
second day three draws yeah today three
wins but he didn't get the words he
didn't get that one yes no lost in the
seventh round but now finally he wins
the first game
and let's jump to Zagreb and speak with
thesselin himself
we're here with Vaseline to Buffalo he
just won a crazy game against Evan
sarich Russell take it away what
happened
well uh apparently my knowledge is a bit
uh outdated because I believe that uh
what he did at the beginning playing
with the bishop on E6 was Julius but
apparently apparently I mean
ever since I started this line it was
considered not so good but apparently
there are new lines and it also works so
okay somehow I don't know because here
that's critical and now D5 so okay of
course I could also uh
play them I thought also here uh
Queen H3 also looked interesting but
somehow I was not so sure what to do
after castling I think so okay for
example here
um somehow the move h6i I was not so
sure about also about uh well one second
here after EF
94 yeah well now white has a very good
positional
Advantage but there's a lot of dynamic
and also many people pieces are hanging
so I don't know now it should be good
for black but what I missed was that
well I missed many moves but my original
idea was different here not to places
um
C3 I think was maybe uh yeah I thought I
should go somehow my idea was to
exchange the queen somehow by playing uh
I think there was some move
but
C3 is probably just dubious
and now suddenly what I missed was that
um
after Queen D5 of course I my plan was
to go Queen D3 maybe or I don't well
probably Queen D3 was my plan but there
was some move I uh and then trying to
exchange
so if he takes then I go Queen C2 this
is this was that was my idea ah you have
to go like this
so if black takes my idea was to go like
this and then exchange pieces so I
thought okay with the Knight on e4 black
white has a good position I don't know
if it's a 95 uh yeah 95 Queen D4 no and
maybe and then he just goes to the yeah
right so maybe I can trade my queen and
then
394 but apparently it doesn't work
because black has checks yeah so there's
a lot of Dynamics and um and it looked
pretty uh pretty dubious for me I have
to admit but suddenly I'm lucky that
here after D3 uh
well no in fact my idea was to go
something like Rook D2 but then I saw it
was just not working and I I had to
play Plan B which was B3 and now 93 I
have to admit that it looks very dubious
right because
because
white king is totally unprotected but
for the moment it is true that uh uh
okay Rook D3 obviously is the critical
move and then uh I thought that okay
there are many many uh so that's my my
uh and then C4 yeah this is what uh
that's very nice Texan yeah but that's
not the end because uh apparently there
was some move like taking right and then
he goes like this there's C3 that's
crazy with a Checkmate uh taking wow
then maybe just winning for black if he
well no you pick up both pieces exactly
because I uh exactly because here I'm
oops that's right I'm on time to uh
First Take on C6
uh and then white is winning but uh yeah
and then uh so Queen E5 it's it felt
wrong because the black doesn't really
uh have any threads but I play Knight F1
because uh okay I saw a move like this
but uh something like this take so uh
Knight takes D2 right and then I saw
that black takes
here uh check this looks scary here and
I I somehow didn't know what to do now I
thought it was kind of Perpetual right
because if I go like this yes black
hashtag so maybe it wins because I go up
yeah maybe it was just winning but we're
going up the board yeah somehow it felt
bad because uh and that's that's the
reason I play Knight F1 because my idea
was to Simply slowly collect the D2 Pawn
with uh and keep all the control and I
thought that also Queen G3 is good and I
couldn't see also Knight G3 is also an
idea so
I thought it was a good move simply not
maybe not the best but solid enough we
were both in time travel uh and then
okay this is just not good because now
uh okay The Rook is away and black has
to either black goes for hopeless ending
or keeps the queen but then I just
collect all the pawns from the uh and
then there was one little trick here I
think that here uh I took I think at my
and now I took again
so it looks so okay I don't know about
this move but somehow I got scared about
this and then I don't uh let me see
here here but of course uh of course it
is true that my queen is on G4 somehow I
thought it was on uh G2 because actually
the black queen was there so I started
looking at all these checks but of
course it's just hopeless I can just go
here and maybe not so clear intuition ah
then it does check yeah it goes check or
you play according to the engine Rook H
yeah it could be but maybe it's a bit
style yeah still it's so I just made a
solid move because I felt like black has
zero uh you know all the pieces are
misplayed and I'm uh all endings are
winning so I don't need to calculate
this and of course um
easy yeah Vaseline it seems like you're
seeing a lot of tricks you're seeing a
lot of stuff what's missing to score a
couple more points well no not really
because for example the first date uh
first game today uh I made a move and
then simply uh I thought my queen was on
C on C8 but it was captured on B8 so I'm
seeing some moves but of course I'm also
missing very simple
moves like for example against Magnus
the game I lost uh I simply didn't
realize he could take my bishop and okay
it was not not
decisive because the mistake I made was
later on but okay the very fact you miss
that simple moves that how the Knight
moves it's quite disturbing
um no I'm not really playing well but
the truth is I okay it's uh I'm not
really trained I didn't come with any
training for this and but again I'm
enjoying the organization it's really
great and for me it's first time in
Croatian I really enjoy it feels like
you're getting better and better the
more the tournament gets in uh well okay
at least I think I scored today the
maybe the I had so many good positions
against my major of completely winning
also game one against
Maxima was at some point clearly better
okay but of course it was complicated so
so today I probably won the most
undeserved game from those I played well
it was a fight and you came out ahead so
congratulations on that one one more
rapid game you think you're gonna try to
get the blitz to catch up uh well you
know the open opening ceremony I said
that uh I like Blitz but I thought my
rapid chest was better and it's a total
disaster so imagine how Blitz is
but no it's just around I sometimes I
mean if I kind of free my hand and play
the natural moves I have chances I
believe oh absolutely you're such a
fantastic player thank you for taking
the time to explain this game in detail
we'll let you go one more rapid game
left good luck yeah thank you thank you
Vaseline guys back to the studio in St
Louis last round of the Rapids remember
counts for double very important and
here we have our standings around eight
Muro yeah so alvareza has matured like
imagine taking a lead by not losing he
made the draw but his closest rival
Jordan One Forest has lost uh while he
held for a draw Wesley Soho did not
catch up him yeah Ali Reza feroza on 11
points Wesley saw you're in one Forest
on 10 and Magnus Carlson creeping up
yeah creeping up a very nice MBL also at
nine and then we have our final round
pairings coming up and uh looking
where's our Marquee matchup uh you know
it's one Forest ferrugia undoubtedly two
Young Guns two Gladiators facing each
other
our first place uh ferugia with black
against Jordan dead force and Anastasia
caught up with uh Jordan then forest and
uh we'll see on the other side of this
break after
her interview
[Music]
imagine how is it going for you so far
um yeah I'm very happy of course uh I
just lost a Magnus which is a pity
because you know you're looking forward
to especially playing Magnus I would say
and then didn't really manage to put any
resistance but in the first round today
I managed to beat the pilot which is of
course a big moment and overall I'm very
satisfied yeah I mean you were leaving
after the first round and how was this
feeling you were sharing the first place
yeah I think you didn't really get to
enjoy it because I immediately had to
play Magnus with black so I didn't
really put any thought in that but yeah
overall I'm of course very happy despite
losing to Magnus just now yeah what
about yesterday evening did you get some
comments from your fans your friends
and not not too many maybe from some
close friends but
no I just keep it like rather quiet and
I only messaged maybe with my family a
little bit that's it yeah
tomorrow we're going to have a complete
tournament and I was just wondering
which format do you prefer oh I prefer
Blitz but I'm much better in Rapids I'm
afraid so I like to play Blitz but it's
uh I think it's my worst time control so
kind of looking forward but also you
know I'm a bit bit scared that it's
gonna fall to piece there but we'll see
yeah today it's still one night round to
go against whom are you playing I'm
playing
easy yeah so what are your expectations
I just try not to lose I guess and then
that's about it I'll just try to play
normal game yeah thank you so much all
the best of luck for you thank you too
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone and welcome back to our
grand chess tour
um broadcast I wanted to say but here we
have our standings uh Nero after eight
rounds of Rapid one game left for today
leaving the pack after two draws today
exactly and by coincidence he happens to
play Jordan Bend forest in this next
round game as we see our pairings what's
our Marquee matchup the two youths yeah
what else do we have though sarich
Wisconsin Carson looking to improve the
score before the
blitzings
yes but also we have Wesley cell versus
Shaq what do you think about Shaq at the
moment the up and down yeah up and down
indeed so he bit Magnus which is of
course a big win but then since not so
impressive wonderful and once again this
will be our final rapid game tomorrow is
Blitz
yes Saturday and Sunday nine rounds each
day Christian one player that is
creeping in as well and he is a blitz
specialist is mvl mvl is within Striking
Distance right now nine points
definitely creeping in and we know how
good he is in Blitz he won the blitz
section in uh Paris a couple of years
ago if not even last year as well he's
definitely a force to be reckoned with
when it comes to fast time control so
definitely I'm having my eyes on him as
well and what about my guy farooja you
think he's a pushover in Blitz no
absolutely
interestingly uh for Rapid you can't
really pick someone who is like a rapid
specialist but at least half of the
tournament can be referred as Blitz like
you have young nepo you have that was
yeah
nepo when he gets on a row can just
simply get over here Anastasia with
Wesley so I love it oh that's a good pig
solid Right Wesley uh by the way Wesley
undefeated completely in this event so
far right I mean just very very smooth
one thing about Wesley uh and Fabiano
told me this he hates losing yes he
really hates losing so he avoids it now
this sometimes gives him a very
conservative type of play nevertheless
when you don't lose and you occasionally
win some games you can find yourself in
pole position and this is exactly or at
least he's very close to that pole
position right now one of the most
unique players in this regard I have to
say is Vaseline topolov so many players
whether it be Gary Kasparov Bobby Fisher
Anatoly karpov just hated losing they
could win two games they have a lose one
game and they'll talk about their losses
for the whole evening not about their
two wins conversely we have we have one
vessel in topolov in the field who
always was swinging for the fences
losses did not deter him in the least it
was sort of like his attitude was they
come with the territory I'm going to
lose a lot of games but I'm going to win
know a lot of games and here he is The
Old Pro himself at age 47 from Bulgaria
2005 fide world champion from San Luis
and well he was a force to be reckoned
with in that tournament as I think he
scored six and a half out of seven in
the first half or six out of seven it
was amazing he just stormed the world
championship in that year it was
definitely vessel in topolov he worked
very bright he was very dominant for a
couple of years exactly and then he
slowed down but when he was at his Peak
condition he was Unstoppable such a
scary force yeah Gary Kasparov louded
him as a kind of a dynamic player in his
own style and it was High Praise indeed
from Gary Kasparov as we see the players
entering the stage a quick thoughts
mirror what has impressed you on this
day three of Rapids uh what did we have
once again yeah well finally Napa
winning a game
you know like Pleasant to see
right and you're gonna have to say
Jordan even though he lost the constant
so far it can happen to anybody right
very like a fantastic tournament for
Jordan and
yeah and here they are the youngsters at
the board 19 years young Ali farouza
there on the right Jordan again is 23 I
believe yep uh one of the youngest
winners of the Dutch Championship he I
think he was 16 at the time he entered
the competition as a wild card and
wouldn't you know it he ends up winning
the tournament
as we have a Berlin
or a Choco piano Bishop B5 and we have
[Music]
Berlin everybody we've all been
converted to the Berlin
uh Vladimir kramnik will never live this
down I mean he he did it against Gary
Kasparov and ever since
we've been playing Berlin what has
Christian what has Jordan's uh Auntie
Berlin been or does he go into the
ending I'm not 100 sure okay master I I
haven't studied Jordan as much
um we're about to find out well there's
your answer does he play D4 does he play
rookie one
rookie one we've seen so many draws on
that line but D4 this ending
um he's trying to remember you can see
it on his face he's closing his eyes
trying to uh pick the line that he
remembers the best and this is the most
important thing in this rapid time
controls play something that you
remember and create some problems for
your opponent it's very unlikely to
create problems small problems small
problems keep keep the position peaceful
as this create some small problems and
try to take it from there all right
we're going to leave this position sorry
uh to be a spoil sport but I want more
action
where would you like to go against MBL
just for a second I mean it's not good
because I'm very excited with the
position but could you kind of move few
moves back then say Bishop C4 is fine
yeah Bishop E6 and then I have a
question is it different from topalo's
game and the answer is not and remember
what Vaseline said so apparently my
knowledge is a bit outdated because
Bishop E6 was considered to be bad right
and now Dominguez doesn't even in girl
photo's line he gives Bishop B3
sometimes he's really Vaseline has to
brush well he's opening analysis exactly
one question guys is Magnus at the board
because I haven't seen a move but he's
Magnus at the board that's a short
question yeah and here I just arrived
and how many minutes did he well forfeit
for yeah for that can we see the clock
right now he also has a little annoyed
look on his face like something uh had
taken him off of his stride that he was
a little bit late for the game I know
that's a couple of minutes right at
least yeah a couple of minutes that's
not bad oh I know Knight C6
but E6 taimanov
we'll see there is still an attempt to
go for
uh yeah you're right A6 yeah I thought
you could go Knight F6 Knight C6 and
invited suspecting the car through a
different move order but A7 A6 uh for
those of you who
you know are not under a rock there was
a wonderful wonderful outing during the
candidates tournament where Magnus
fresh from his stint in Las Vegas goes
to the park
and plays against Judith Polgar a Blitz
game and uh comes up with the time on
off and
ends up getting destroyed all right
maybe the official commentator that
Judith Polgar and it was a very nice
moment go to YouTube uh look it up
because it was a very fun outing Bishop
A7 is this what they call the con yes
you should put the time enough we we
we're never really sure how these
openings
the what the polo guyevsky Bishop A7
variations
yeah yeah I mean it could be that this
one this is the Khan polygous
yes so you know what
um the most confusing for me in naming
all those openings it used to be enough
in our books you know called it was all
called Paulson Paul senses yes exactly
right and then they've invented that
this specific one is Tai man of this
one's Khan and so on it was called
Paulson Sicilian please oh yeah
and what do we think of uh saricha's
approach
uh to this I think definitely the most
testing this idea of exchanging dark
Square Bishops yeah because you want to
take advantage of the newly created
weaknesses both on the queen side as
well as in the center that's called D6
only two games by the way that's rare at
this point so that's pretty rare oh for
sure
um okay if I'm white I'm I'm thinking I
want to play the move E5 for a myriad
number of reasons not the least of which
is I'd like this bishop to be open and
also to control some dark squares but
I'm thinking this night since I haven't
committed it to C3 92.
E5 Knight C4 and Knight D6 would be the
dream come true
um am I worried about D5 Mira after
Knight D2
um
that's a kind of a semi-tempo alpha
tempo
I might play Just B7 B6 and ask Knight
C6 Knight C6 will be six yeah Knight C6
quickly played it does seem like Yvonne
is still aware of uh no it's the best
moves in the position this is making the
best moves in the position right now
you mean engine approved engine database
no there's no more games in the database
wow but these are engine approved all of
them Queen to E3 followed by Knight to
C3 these last few moves by white
indicate to me that he's thinking of
going long
as opposed to castling short
Christian Jump Right In would you oh
he's definitely getting ready to go
along yes absolutely absolutely not only
that but for example think about the
move D5 right it looks like it creates a
lot of problems right right now but uh
the problem for black is that after take
take on D5 with the pawn we exchange
that and you're getting ready to go D4 I
can go Castle right and then even after
you go with D4 I can just simply move uh
the queen away and then you're going to
have to contend with all all sorts of
Bishop takes H7 ideas D4 the results I
think maybe even I take four words which
is which is not very often yes yeah
it takes I can take on H7 you take on H7
King H7 Rook D4 and it continues because
when the queen moves it's Rook H4 and
take the Rook very nice nice and you
don't have Knight to F5 because Queen H3
Queen to H3 track wow so that's that's a
beautiful tactic by the way yeah because
you would stop somewhere here yeah the
queen H3 it's a tactic because
well you can just take and take on f8
yeah but I I think this is not I think
no I think he has analyzed this position
yes he's playing so fast I think he has
some knowledge about this position even
sarish that is how deep is are these
players preparations
like you can't surprise anybody these
days anymore but then you do see these
unusual moments where you're in novel
territory after move five so
it's confusing yeah well sometimes yes
I'm really surprised well with the moves
that they are surprised with
foreign's novelty against Carson on what
move five move six right exactly this
was the line that was already played for
a couple of years and a lot of
discussion and the whole kind of key
points were coming around move 15 yeah
and could this be that nobody checked
before it seems like secret agreement we
only played this line starting from I
don't know move 12 right and then you
have the variety of options and then we
all breaks the agreement says okay I'll
go E6 I'll go D5 I'll equalize in 15
minutes right
sometimes they kill you surprising yeah
uh Christian what game has caught your
attention as uh I was looking at most of
them and most of them do seem uh quite
balanced up to uh this point an
interesting game in the Dominguez versus
mvl game and we know that mvl is very
close within Striking Distance from the
leaders dominions on the other hand
haven't been uh really feeling himself
in this tournament so he definitely
needs a victory in this one and he has a
really good position I have to say this
end game definitely some pressure you're
going to see the route coming to D1 a
lot of pressure on the D file and also
you have some space on the queen side
given by this advancement of the a pawn
so I like wise chances nevertheless also
mvl he's such a specialist in the night
array so difficult to beat him in this
typical structures because he knows even
when he's worse he knows where to put
the pieces and uh that's also extremely
important when you're talking about the
rapid chess he plays fast he's going to
put a lot of pressure on you uh some
Echoes going on here between the game of
nepo and vessel and topolov and that
variation you just showed of Dominguez
because white was having that pressure
but in this case vesselyn has gotten in
the the desired d6d5 break even though
it's cost of a Pawn on A6
um
initiative versus the pawn yeah this
seems to be a very strong initiative if
you ask me well at least I'm looking at
the line where you take on D5 yeah it
captures with well yes
Knights getting traded Bishop F2 and it
seems like a lot of jumping that night
before is insane Rook d8 is the thing
yeah Bishop how do you defend after
night before yeah that's the thing
a lot of things yes a lot of it's a big
question right
go Bishop D3 I think you take on B3 and
rook d8 and you might have already been
deep deep trouble that that's very
embarrassing uh getting the double pawns
and
and suffering a pin we do have takes on
D5 and I'm sure we're going to see
Knight takes D5 hola Tempo here okay so
how do we defend you cannot get off the
G1 A7 diagonal because then you have to
contend with Queen to A7 that picks up
the bishop so how
how do you stabilize the position that's
why
we into D2 not happy I don't like that
move
I need a better move Queen to D3 also
not happy 23 Knight to B4 yeah terrible
that Bishop F2 is needed Knight before
Bishop like F1 or something and then
just play that position I can't abandon
this A7 Square uh no a move like Bishop
D two simply walk B6 or bna7 just drops
a piece exactly
right
[Music]
nepo is not uh
it's not having the time of his life in
this tournament he's
he seems to be an off
I think we should definitely move to uh
the leaders please right because we do
have uh two leaders that's van forest
and alireza and they're facing each
other right now actually no never mind
fam 4 is just lost he was the leader
going into the last round but he lost uh
okay so we lost interest in this game
after they've played rookie one right
the anti-burling but maybe the interest
coming back because remember this line
where the punandifa was sacrificed
that's exactly the line we have on the
board okay just a second we're looking
at the alireza game versus
One Forest where are you there yeah okay
there it is so we have seen this Pawn
sacrifice that Wesley purposefully
declined and Ali raise it
is that the move I thought everybody's
playing Bishop F4 uh it's somewhat
confusing because why it usually starts
with Bishop F4 and then this position
comes about like white plays Bishop F4
then black trades only one takes the
pawn on D4 and yeah in this position
Knight B1 to C3 is dimension right so
what white does is basically an argument
that Bishop D3 is better for move than
Bishop F4 okay at least to start with
uh so as I understand it you would like
to play Bishop F4 and queen E4 and take
advantage it takes me a while to uh I
don't have time to go 98 right now yeah
well yeah that's the biggest kind of
biggest difference because 98 is a known
myth in this other line but now it's
Queen E4 and we're embarrassed but maybe
you have to just give up the bishop can
I play B6
Knight B5 would be my guess
[Music]
at least he's getting tricky at least I
was hoping that this is going to work
maybe okay let's see if it works take on
B5 Queen E4 of course doesn't work
give it back give it back ah so you want
to do this
because I'm thinking that uh but I like
take I'll be safe
I I want to track meet you that's like a
lot of checks in a row and usually it's
a good thing let's see if you can count
Bishop G5 one more okay oh by the way
yeah yeah at the very end I can just
regain the peace yes I absolutely have
to say so for example if you go Bishop
F6 yeah
very good and then I pick up on G5 and
B5 with a weak King so yes that nothing
that is not good news not good at all no
you're playing for free yeah so that's
interesting will Wesley
um
Wesley already managed not to lose this
yeah
um
if 98 is a bad news uh can I try just
like maybe G6 hide the bishop on G7 or
whatever
yes I I just want to I think I want to
give up that Bishop
what Bishop F4 now Bishop takes C3
instead of G6 I I don't like Nike I
immediately taken yeah three okay but
then and he took it he took on C3 okay
here I have to just pause I mean I don't
like the damaged Pawn structure but uh
Queen takes E3 I'd like somehow keeping
control over E5 he took with the queen
right away by the queen you know and
well 98 right
what else otherwise Bishop F4 and rookie
one
um it only makes sense because you're
ready to conceit three right every India
has played 98.
so one played D6 D6 and get the bishop
out as fast agreed agreed
okay so where's the compensation
two Bishops compensation our favorite
our favorite assessment competency I
remember having breakfast with Gary
Kasparov I had lost the game in the
previous round against Vladimir kramnik
and I said Gary yeah
damn it I lost yesterday what was my
problem
kramnik
Gary said two Bishops I passed the
yogurt
two Bishops that's the compensation but
okay tell me how am I supposed to uh
organize my pieces should I put my
Bishop on D4 should I put right how how
do I compensate with two Bishops it's
really not an easy question to answer
right now
right the engine is saying something
along the lines of B4 uh B3 was played
put a bishop on B2 but even once you put
the bishop B2 I will be able to block
that whenever I want with the move
Knight to F6 so
I think it is white who is on the back
foot he needs to find a way to
potentially get the pawn back or at
least transition into a more peaceful
situation right now he's just spawned
out yeah and here again uh interestingly
enough I'm not attracted to the move D5
at all not the least of reasons why
potentially there would even be Bishop
A3 and rookie one when the pawn is on D5
not so easy to uh block that dark long
diagonal but something like D6 Bishop
here and I don't know Bishop E6 Queen
can come out to G5 later somehow this
Knight on E8 makes a pleasing impression
it defends C7 it defends G7 not easy to
prove the compensation if you forgive me
I'd like to go to the game of Magnus
Carlson Yvonne sarage what is going on
the rookon A7 has managed to find a home
on C7
5
I love these games where players are
castled on opposite wings
Queen C8
G4 okay let's go G4
and again your first impressions oh
first impression that white somehow gets
space somewhere gets space gets to
attack uh the black king yeah before
Knight F4 perhaps is crucial so the
whole question is if you can take on C2
or perhaps the answer is not because
Knight B6 and something like D7 Falls
with straight effect
um
it's interesting to note that Yvonne did
not include the A2 A3 because I played
A3 but decided not to he may be thinking
that he'd like to keep A4 as a
possibility G4 what what is he doing
going for F5 perhaps he had more F5 than
G5 yeah right okay five and then who
knows good space yeah maybe maybe we
like whites how about you Christian yeah
no it's a very balanced position uh
right now uh from a practical
perspective the way I look at it I do
like white uh he played the move D5
right now these changes completely the
character of the position well he wants
to block the D file you want to play
yeah five that's why right I think sorry
you have to play E5
E5 B4 is uh okay you probably have to
play E5 but then you have to have an
answer so what do I do just maybe play
with the pawn down I sacrifice the pawn
sacrifice the pawn but is that actually
a sacrifice so so let's look at it easy
five yeah can I go after B4 Knight to A4
and try to put a knight on C5
so if Rook takes you you're gonna munch
on another Pawn I I know you yes sir
I cannot stop it's not that it's not
that blackheads I feel like Doctor
Strange Love must take pawns and now
Queen G3 and you put the Rook on H6 are
you gonna be happy with that Rook I'm
not gonna be happy with the Rook I'm
gonna be happy with the two pawns you do
have to pause
though yeah okay to be fair yeah Rook C1
Knight C5 looks like white so those are
complications
this feels like this word always pops up
by the way we do have E5 and B4 B4 on
the board and wait a second and that's
that's the moment on the board as well
maybe we're going straight into that
okay yeah so I was going to
um
massage's interview after he won a game
against Nepal and he said like yeah if
he would have gone for something solid
but for a change he let me play my game
yes right I picked up isn't it his game
it is he he likes the sharp stuff uh
rather than the line we just looked at
uh he took the pawn by the way yeah I
was gonna say let's do it a little bit
positional let's go Knight D4 give me
your Rook yeah
okay uh I'll just show you what I had in
mind as far as this one was concerned
or maybe F5
no I mean this it's easy to believe that
white has like a very strong it looks
very scary and this is what Yvonne is
saying is like give me that position and
will he play Knight D4 or Knight B6 well
one thing we missed yes it seems like is
that after Knight to C5 black has this
very good response brucifer yeah
yeah it is uh Rook C4 no no D4 ah D4 yes
I think I have Knight takes B7 and
Knight to A5 right
oh yeah you're right yeah but D4 opening
up the bishop Knight D5 is also on tap
and also I have an extra Square defended
the G2 Square so whenever I take on H2
you go Queen to G3 I can just simply go
Rook to G2 and save my Rook like that
yeah exactly that that makes a very
pleasing impression which is once again
why Knight D4 stopping that positional
Pawn sacrifice which opens up your
Bishop opens up the D5 Square might be
the uh Right Way
um
this is fascinating stuff uh sorry I'm
just going to go back to the youths
because you know we should see what the
two and we do have D6 and well
um going to be full Queen to beat four
kind of probing trying to you know
provoke something some some weaknesses
wait a minute does that just mean that
wait what do you play
as black right now I'm thinking Queen G5
uh trying to set a pretty crass trap so
you've Queen D7 not very subtle
well
somebody was being brutal in one other
game around here but yes you're right
not very subtle subtly before that
you're unhappy maybe H4 yeah H4 yeah and
queen G4 connection now I take on p7
very nice so he played Bishop D5
immediately right okay defending the
pawn and well intimating that Queen G5
comes next well but maybe now you put
the cream on F4 so you control all the
squares to F4 and this yeah and then
rookie one is coming I can actually see
some play for white it's uh threats
there are threats it's happening like
Bishop H7 for instance already
threatening to win the pawn back and be
say more active in the resulting
position Queen F4 is on the board guys
Queen F4 and I think Queen F5 as well as
you said Bishop page seven Jordan is
filling it you still don't have a clear
way of involving that Rook into play The
Rook on A8 and my next move if you do
defend against Queen to F5 I will go
around yeah I can improve my page you
cannot again age porn marching up the
board
indeed Harry and all of my pieces are
attacking you that's Black's problem
right now even the pawn even the H Pawn
is attacking you time situation 10
minutes for Olive Reza and 20 minutes
four years that's a huge time Advantage
okay so let me play I was about to
defend the bishop with the move C7 C6 to
at least allow my queen this opportunity
Knight F6 well we can easily we can all
guys breaking news though first we have
to go to nepo versus topalov because
topalov just blundered a piece oh no yes
oh really that's a innocuous looking
position and he just blundered a piece
in one move and right now nepo if he
sees Rook to A6 and he seems a little
bit confused yeah
and you can you can only run away with
one Bishop too many Bishops on the B5
that's a beautiful too many pieces on
the B file that's a beautiful Motif
traffic jam on the B file as you simply
don't have time to run away that is
crazy you uh
uh and specifically Rook A6 right you
have something else
haven't probably
what's the refutation let's see
okay we don't know but but yeah but the
Rook A6 is enough for sure maybe F5
after okay seven yeah so what was the
innocuous move G6
time to draw the basics on the board and
yeah Nepal speeds up wow an apple
finishing the day with two victories in
a row
is he back this is over this game is
actually interesting you just dropped
one of the Bishops that is really uh a
big surprise and there you see the shake
of the head
that uh the funny part is that my queen
is connected to the bishopon B4 if you
try to kick the queen away with F5 yeah
I move on to the next Bishop Queen to E3
and you still have I'm always connected
to one of your Bishops with my queen and
then Rook to B6 is coming next again
[Laughter]
don't take the bishop with check you
just go back uh wow uh for vessel and
again it kind of rains and it pours uh
uh really a shocking moment there
because it's just a lapse all you have
to do drop the bishop to f8 and it's
absolutely normal position right and
even a vesselman is looking at this
saying oh my God this is like
crazy I can't save my Bishops on the
open file all right well as he's
suffering uh Wesley so versus Shaq what
the heck is going on here okay something
something's happening
um
well uh kind of looks like Shaq is
throwing the the kitchen sink at Wesley
Knight F3 check
and the checkmate
yeah I can I can handle the bishop on H4
by taking the Rook but it's this
Checkmate that uh hurts my feelings Rook
E4
wow
um
I take on F3 uh you take on E3 and H3
um
H4 like continuing to abuse the pins you
know
maybe with the rook and go Knight H5 you
know Knight H5 okay so sometimes sure
this isn't exactly what Wesley had in
mind when he was playing the last round
with the white pieces he didn't expect
that his King was going to become under
such an assault well the the black king
is getting under an assault in the game
between van forest and furuja as well
take a look at what happened there
everything is coming into play Queen to
F4 followed by Rook to E3 Rook to E1 and
Rook to E3 I'm getting to G3 or F3
you're in big big trouble right now
exactly okay oh dear uh Knight D5
however Knight D5 is a fork is there
well I can stop you with uh Roku G3
right oh pardon me it's actually it's
actually white smoke not only that yeah
yes I was a small details so pleased to
tell you I would be pleased to tell you
that after Knight D5 I have that move or
this maybe forward in a queen G3
something right Bishop Jesus
but my turn uh King and maybe I can now
that he put the King on f8 maybe I can
even start with Rook to F3
Rook to F3 well then I'm not moving
that's okay but how do you improve the
position because I think I'm starting to
have threats such as Queen to G5 Queen
to G5 threats
first of all how do you defend against
Queen H4
yeah Queen H4 is not bad at all Queen G5
I see you have maybe Knight to E8 but
Queen to H4 okay uh
I will start I suppose with obsession
with H6 right H6 any Queen moves I think
I'm dropping back to either G8 or E8
probably EA in that case I'm going to go
Queen to E3 right now you don't have the
drop back because I have Queen takes C6
yeah and then next move Bishop takes F6
next move Queen
this might be problematic Rook F3 is one
of those moves that you know kind of
freezes them up but I do have Bishop D5
sorry rookette uh do do we have it on
the board we don't know Rook F3 Bishop
D5 and now I move to G3 C4
by the way isn't that crafty stopping my
knight D5 you know and vision B5 yeah
C4 yeah
I believe you I believe you still keeps
it
uh all the pressure still is on black
side of the board also on Black's time
right now and that was my next question
what is the clock times still on 19
minutes really wow yeah you already
speaking kind of in the book right and
then only seven minutes for alireza I
know it's still in his book I was going
to say and for uh farusha am I wrong in
thinking he's the no Wesley is
undefeated West is undefeated as well as
ferrugia but Wesley is under attack
against
attack here yeah right and if Jordan
happened to win this game then he
catches up
it's actually not about being undefeated
it's about winning games because he lost
two but he won too many exactly
and Magnus Carl so he actually doesn't
catch up he lived frogs exactly
yeah wins
as nepo finishes day three in style in
fact Luke A6 just uh it was resignation
after that they didn't see a movie six
was terrible
okay back to our youth as we see Jordan
then for us enjoying his position as
well as a Time advantage c2c4 and we're
struggling ourselves uh we need a
suggestion for uh Ali Reza
[Laughter]
H6 seems to be like the best move in the
position but okay there's something
along the lines of what you were doing
after Rook of three right yeah but this
is very tricky kind of felt uh and maybe
now that you have an extra move you can
start off with Queen to E7 which at
least defends your Bishop on E6 so after
Queen E3 you can drop back without a
second it's G4 removed by any chance I
don't know why I want to play G4 which
is to highlight my tactical telling
exactly
so that it works you know like we'd like
to build up a rep reputation as a
Fearless attacker very well especially
since those are not my pawns right
and look at these guys who are just
getting started no wins at all between
the three drawers wow okay I wouldn't
have guessed that uh the young guys tend
to swing for the fences we just had the
US Junior seniors and girls an
unbelievable number of decisive games
nobody was making drugs even the seniors
it's like what's going on the seniors uh
got uh got Juiced and to uh emphasize
the fact of Ali Reza's age he's actually
four years younger than Jordan
that's 40 years younger four years it's
he's so young so like both youngsters
but the one is Jordan already feels like
an old man compared
uh Knight H5 that's not a good move
nobody cannot be nobody likes this move
by the way it just looks like an awful
move first of all the bishop is hanging
so Rook takes E3 is met by Knight takes
F4 we understand but we play Queen to F3
threatening
Rook takes as well as Queen takes
I guess you just want to go back and
then in the immortal words of my trainer
and dear beloved friend who passed
Nikolai minute gift me the pawn we have
threes on the board Queen F3 and Knight
that's back to F6 what
that was a terrible move
Knight H he just couldn't find a single
move well age six we thought I I guess
he just believed that H6 doesn't improve
his cause
no but there is also a threat of Bishop
F6 and you will have to take with the
pawn like say Rook ba yes among other
things I have so this is my yes if you
do play Queen takes B7 I think what he
wants is fine finally some sort of
active play with D5
D5 I I think it's the only thing that
makes sense uh but how about Bishop F6
again I'm not saying it's good right
okay maybe his only hope
Jordan would like to get into the pond
Grove never mind
him being trying to be active but he
goes for Knight G4 which apparently
makes the situation even worse
what is this what is going on he's back
to losing games okay he didn't lose yet
but I mean the the to playing the way he
was playing in the candidates it's a
little bit childish exactly but no no no
no no no this coffee house
attack something go back wait for your
opponent to to blunder but these guys
they are not blundering very often too
Rook G3 it's too suggestive
yeah to take his side for a second he
only has four minutes on the clock
that's the problem he needs to make a
move
I understand his moves are not good but
he needs to make he needs to play
something Bishop takes G7 check followed
by H2 H3 is on tap for white everything
is on top then right now then Black's
structure is destroyed and his King is
loose so Jordan my goodness
in this one I still it feels like a long
time ago but I still remember his first
interview with
um Alejandro where he had started
tournament two out of two and said that
he had played in the Blitzen rapid where
he only scored two victories and he had
already matched his his performance so
the entire tournament exactly uh and
look at this
does not have the look of a person
I guess you can so yeah so what do you
do in such situations because you can't
even pick up another Point that's what I
want to do yeah yeah
but seriously I believe Queen E4
objectively is the better move but what
I do I just yeah because we need four
hits H7 yeah and it hits the night no
but it's such a pleasant choice choice
and it's such a pleasant feeling when
you take on A7 basically asking your
opponent okay you you were struggling on
a previous move now it's the same
problem but Pawn down right tell me how
to get out of here
with this beautiful uh Pawn sacrifice
again and normally speaking of course
you you you were thinking that you're
activating your Rook until you oh oh
yeah uh that it was not falls apart what
it's all about Queen takes A7 but Queen
E4 what a what a marvelous choice
it's very hard not to play such a move
because it's just sort of like a kind of
a
well not ping pong but you're just
hitting geometrically you're hitting the
pawn on H7 every possible angle yes yeah
pinball I wanted to say kind of uh oh
yeah yeah hitting all of the the bumpers
nice uh this is completely over wow
busted
what a game what a game
it's a G5 and a little Pawn movement and
maybe there'll be something yeah like
some Queen d2s no nobody believes you as
Ben would say H3 queen dito queen D2
Bishop takes G7 check ah yeah so you're
settling for such a maybe you want more
well
no those are two teenagers it makes um
I can start with Queen takes each so
we could start with Queen takes keep the
two Bishops you mean not playing H3 not
H3 just Queen takes H7 fair enough
I must admit if you're going to put it
like that a couple of Pawns up and the
two Bishops I can resist everything
except Temptation
Queen H7 uh sir sure does look good
sure does
and the problem is that even if you do
get to uh D2 and then somehow you
deliver the check on the first rank I
still have Bishop F1 yeah I agree you're
like so far away from delivering any
sort of damage to my position exactly
exactly and in the meanwhile your your
king might just end up
uh
uh destroyed okay the vultures are here
yes yes yes yes yes and we're we're
we're warming gleefully our hands
um any other games uh catching your
interest at the moment again just to
remind everybody we do have our first
result in round nine our final result
our final uh game of today Rapids nepo
has won a miniature the the Magnus game
is is quite wild and it's hitting up but
I think we should stay with that one
just until we see the resignation
there's still plenty of time left in the
other ones are you sure this Magnus game
is amazing there's also crazy but
amazing game it is it is indeed okay
farugia again we're expecting
uh Queen takes H7 and or H3 we think
that Jordan Bend force is winning but
this is the Magnus Carlson yeah Magnus
Carlson's theme it is crazy and it's it
seems like he also went wrong at some
point because he didn't remember yeah
can't be suggesting that uh he was he
was shall I go to that game I believe
shall I go to that game it's uh it's
it's a crazy game this is yes this is
the game where Knight D4 we were arguing
but H4 which I love D4 yeah sorry before
it seems that yeah Black is Black is
good in fact Knight D5 was better than
Bishop D5 doesn't matter let's look at
the but F6 is just blown up the whole
position now I'm assuming it's Queen
takes E5 but Knight D7 yeah 25 Knight D7
there's no way exactly
so the desirable Queen takes E5 Knight
D7 with the idea of Knight F6 hurts the
feelings
so what do we do then take fe5
that is you probably have to right right
well e F6 and mate otherwise so let's
take a look if we take
I mean there's a wild move Rook to d8
but that makes absolutely no sense from
a human's perspective Rook to D yeah
that just we're not going to see that
only
okay but let's imagine uh and now how
does white continue
G4 yeah Magnus captures on G4 I briefly
thought about this and um so he gives it
yeah 95 is the point yes Square I wasn't
sure but I didn't like it Queen F6 yeah
how do we reply to Queen F6 because
Knight F5 I guess white can take the
bishop
right Queen F6 like the five Rook D5 man
I'm just still uh catching up with the
uh there's a great move and pattern in
the position right now Rook takes D5
Knight E6 ah that was Knight B6
I missed it right it's all about getting
that Knight towards F6 correct but he
didn't that's fine this is the human's
perspective just take on F6 with a
question King H7 by the way the move
Magnus ended up playing is the only move
the only move uh not intuitively obvious
by the way to get into trouble but now
he might be even better after King H7
that is crazy because apparently the
king is safe believe it or not
hiding behind the white pawn and it's
funny because I want to take on D5 and I
want to be able to give a queen F5 check
right but you have this really really
annoying Intermezzo like Rook takes D5
Knight yes and if you yeah if you're
trying to be brilliant kind of
sacrificing to exchange yeah double
exchange sacrifice the Frozen style yeah
right G1 and unfortunately even Knight
E6 is no longer playable as well so okay
um
King H7 uh Christian Jump Right In uh
tell us what uh Yvonne sarich needs to
do to
to stay competitive you mean to stay uh
to keep zero zero good on the board uh
Rook to C1 seems to be the best movie in
the position
hiking
get behind that there's nothing
immediate happening and this is the
point in this position you have to
understand that sure you're getting very
close to the black king but you don't
have enough resources so what you do
need to do is just stabilize uh the
position as it is Rook to C1 does that
the thing is we talk about the
Superfluous nights this Knight on A4
these pieces are working the night on E7
the bishop on D5 Knight on A4 is not
working Rook C1 I understand releases
perhaps ideas of Knight to B6 followed
by Knight to D7 exactly yeah so that's
why I can get behind this move Rook
scene also Rook to C1 I mean there's a
threat right Knight takes C6 that's
that's a big one so you do need to get
the Queen off the C file after that
right
okay and it makes sense right I mean
well it also defense you you when you
play the move Rook C1 and I if you force
me to move my queen I have to Rook to
see one is on the board I I have to
maintain contact with the D7 Square I
think you have to go Crazy Eights queen
d8 queen A7 but definitely
and by the way guys it does seem like
firuja is not giving up just yet did not
resigned just yet and we were calling in
the priests and the last rites what
happened he found some tactics in the
position he found or Jordan missed seven
wait a second Queen H7 was Blade the
move that we were suggesting was good
right F three
defends F2 check we always had this move
but Knight H2
keeping
the initiative alive King takes H to
Queen F1 now it's not so much about the
initiative right now but I think it's
just about the fact that my king finally
is a bit safe on D7 agreed
agreed with that that's that that is
true so you are a pawn up but my king at
least has found some shelter yeah you
were getting black well Black's King was
getting blasted on the king side and if
it does make a little kind of uh a jaunt
to the C6 Square you'll be fine
um
Jordan is one
only minimal material as well right it's
five versus four and right now once
again it comes down to that time
situation one minute and 55 seconds for
Ali Reza and 11 minutes for it you're
still maintaining a very significant
lead on the clock okay but now I need to
do something very serious I I I think I
need to uh open up the king a little bit
uh with them and that's the Practical
move as well right right you're putting
immediate pressure on the blacking
exactly I like that
in order I have a queen G5 check so that
was a bit worried about Rook before and
then get into G4 maybe that's the way
for black to include the rook in the
game but yeah but C5 is on the board
nice move by your Rook to G4 now the
question is after G4 yeah you'll take F7
can I yeah I was actually thinking about
taking on D6 and going Bishop F6
followed by Queen to f8
um be careful there's a mate on G2 right
yeah
black lifts The Rook could be four right
yes that is the idea so who's
checkmating who first is the question
right by the way you know what you have
C6 and perhaps I just can't stop Bishop
uh Bishop check and then Queen h8 that's
that's the biggest box that's her and
you don't actually look at that move yes
it takes it it's because it's obviously
yeah I'm playing to open the position
yeah you've played C5 in order to
capture that by the way C6 is a threat
now I realize
it's a very hidden move right I maybe we
have to play a little awkward like 87
perhaps and then uh they could always be
inside yeah but then white exchanges
girls maybe even Queen D4 switching the
flanks you know yes with the pawn on A7
hanging with this structure I believe
what should be winning again
by the way guys Magnus down to his last
three minutes against eight minutes
for Ivan sarich so there's some time
trouble brewing in that one as well and
we do have a move by
he's allowed C6 did did I see that right
verusia Queen to D1
he's allowing C6
[Music]
yes and he plays
this game it's game okay guys that was a
hidden move it was a beautiful it's a
beautiful beautiful tactic that alirez
wow
unbelievable nobody from us picked him
for a winner I'm ashamed of you all how
dare you and well at least it's it's
comforting to know that yasad was just
as far away as every well everyone else
I just wanted to say I had a horse in
that race let me tell you something uh
wow
C5 C6 and that's a beautiful finish maid
is coming with bishop and Nate wow let's
switch our game over to the Magnus
Carlson because that's been a Donnie
Brook for some time uh help us out uh
Christian what have you been discovering
about this game I have been watching the
Ali Reza that C6 I haven't been
discovering anything but right now uh it
does seem like black has managed to
defend his King's position and is taking
over the initiative given the fact that
those two nights are really badly placed
this is the definition of Superfluous
Knights exactly
okay one good thing is the night on C5
is always working first of all we stop
Bishop E4 then if we ever transfer our
Knight to F6 it's gold how about we play
a move like B3 sure let's get the Knight
to F5
to get why not yeah that's
where am I putting my queen that's the
problem my king is so safe right now
right
on H7 it's crazy it actually is it's
very safe and I have a lot of targets to
work with even in the end game your E5
H5 pawns are not going to be uh assets
but rather reliabilities agreed
um I'm still actually I'm still musing
uh over where do I put my queen okay I'm
picking a square let's go yeah Queen G5
and you want to go to F6 right let's go
Rook G8
my plan was to answer Rook G8 with the
tickle Queen F6
um
that's why perhaps Magnus
Knight H6 wait he did play some move we
just wore oh no B3 was not yet played no
b i I saw it yeah so uh B3 Knight F5 no
and you were saying H6 986 yeah let's go
back yeah okay this works as well but
but then why don't we start with Rook G8
I mean instead of Knight F5 yeah if you
would like to keep the Knight on H6 you
as miros that's a good point you don't
need uh that is a good point uh maybe
you at the same time wait wait wait a
minute so let's leave the Knight on F5
your queen is sort of Trapped it's true
on F6 so maybe I can go Queen to E8 back
but that allows night yeah
I I don't want to allow this no no no
Queen's idea loans is six for the time
being like restricting both noise yeah
but there's something
Charming about this night yeah the night
I'm holding F7 and maybe
G8 Rook G2 and then we'll see where the
knights go wow
um
you know even when he's not doing well
magnus's games are somehow
you know
magnetic they they draw you in and you
start thinking to yourself
he's he's such a gifted player that he
comes up with he's
this is a really remarkable conception
of keeping your king safe on an open G
file yeah right
wow wait a minute so if Magnus wins this
one he's going to go to 11 points and
catch up with Ali Reza only one point
behind your which is what he said that
in his interview with Alejandro if he
goes into the blitz just a mere two
points behind he will be happy uh one
point behind fantastic we have a draw
yeah that's a draw for Dominguez and
mbls apologies we didn't follow anything
in particular happening in happened in
that game between mvl and yeah started
it started similar to the polyps game
remember that this is nice and then we
abandoned it I mean just had some pool
in the end game but I didn't manage to
do anything with it yeah
let's be fair for a good reason because
there was this one Forest game and also
Carlson's game both of which wait a
minute Yvonne actually was the one who
got yeah
and Rook G1 Bob maybe that's a smart
thing to do because otherwise black
would have taken and and you know you no
longer have
B3 I guess as a move we can always play
but again I was looking to
bring these Knights into the game by the
way just I just saw Wesley so and
shackery are out of the corner of my eye
and I thought
well did Wesley again somehow magically
saved it did yeah well it seems to save
that I mean it looked at some point it
looked really bad he's good at saving
lost positions that's remarkable not
only it did look bad it was completely
lost let's be fair only completely lost
that
but let's jump to Zagreb Alejandro and
our tournament leader
we're here with the tournament leader
Jordan van Forrest tell us how's it feel
yeah pretty surreal I have to say it
didn't expect this at all of course um
but yeah I don't know the the like the
games I'm winning everything is really
flowing smoothly for me and I'm really
getting the kind of positions which I
like so
thank you for those positions let's get
us started with here we had a Berlin yes
were you aware that this particular
Berlin had been played before in this
tournament
what I saw alireza but with Knight C3 as
well because I thought alireza played
like C3 against Wesley as well Dominguez
Wesley saw in round one he won Bishop F4
oh no I didn't see this uh Bishop D3
part of your prep yeah I actually
prepared it for topalos but um I I was
choosing a little bit of lines
especially because of the here I have a
lot of choice and it's like black is
completely fine but with the two Bishops
in Rapid it can get tricky as the game
showed and there's a lot of ways but I
thought B3 is very tricky because
actually D6 series is inaccurate like
you have to play D5 but it looks humanly
looks kind of strange to weaken all the
dark squares and I believe like of the
bishop B2 you should still play D flat
according to the computer which is very
hard for a human and after that it I
think it's really much better for white
I knew this queen before ID as well wow
that's amazing a very strong preparation
and very practical in some ways kg that
you're trying to get your opponents to
make natural moves that seem like
mistakes yeah it tries but I mean in
Rapid it can work out very well and
classical like these lines they're
easily refuted and the opponents will
find all the moves but in Rapid it's
very hard to like navigate your way
through such a little bit complicated
lines where the bone has some initiative
I would say take us a little bit of some
of the key mistakes of course is
unpleasant but it's not lost where did
you feel he was starting to lose the
threat uh yeah so I knew like Queen G5
here is very logical but then there's
Queen before
um so after Bishop E6 I figured Queen B4
also is to move because otherwise he can
play Queen F6 right if he tries Queen F6
here I think there's Queen E1 and I'm
yeah so I mean then immediately I really
like my position and around here I was
expecting him to play H6 actually which
um apparently the computer move and
after Rook G3 king of f8 and I didn't
really see how to break through but
um
aha yeah I actually sold Bishop the xh7
like after I played C4 oh but anyway the
white position is really easy to play
here and I thought maybe you should try
D5 here but I wasn't
I wasn't like dissatisfied here and it's
just in time travel also for him it's
very hard position to play and all the
white moves are just coming so naturally
you had a huge time advantage over him
and then he hits you with the tactic
Knight Queen to the background Knight
takes H2 do you feel that you were
letting it go or did you feel in control
yeah well with alireza you have to be
extremely careful he's not only he's
just so incredibly tricky so Knight
takes H2 I did miss indeed but I I
immediately realized okay I'm still up
to pawns you know and my king is not
checkmated oh but actually um it's not
so clear afterwards I see my computer
but I thought it should still be winning
um actually I'm only at one point but I
thought like his King is much more
insecure with the C5 it looked really
strong still for me so I was not no no
but it wasn't the best technique I would
say still good enough for a rapid game
how do you feel going into the blitz you
consider yourself a blitz specialist no
no little one terrible one blitz so
don't tell my opponents but uh yeah no I
think I like rapid is actually my best
time control and Blitz is my worst but I
enjoy playing Blitz the most so I'll
just try to enjoy and take whatever
point I can but it's gonna be very tough
for sure well you're nursing a nice
Advantage you're going to be going into
the blitz as solo first places we don't
expect Wesley to win his game actually
let's go there immediately see how
that's going well it seems like a drawn
end game yeah some white has to be
careful but I guess the king is just in
time to pick up those pawns on the queen
side absolutely so you're going to be
guaranteed first place going into the
blitz good job so far good luck in the
blitz thank you so much guys back to the
studio just a couple of games left in
the Rapids here in Zagreb thank you
Alejandro thank you Jordan you hear this
I'm terrible
our audiences were like if he's terrible
where am I mean come on I'm bossing my
black belt in modesty to this little
chap I mean it was it was such a
pleasant interview to listen to exactly
no and and don't trust him one bit
Jordan is actually very dangerous in
Blitz and he enjoys it a lot but yes
he's he's tempering the expectations of
his fans jumping into the Magnus Carlson
game looky looky the night is trying to
find the cookie Knight F6 check on tap
suddenly did what when Magnus once again
I don't really like it
just a second what's going on guys
Knight F6 Yvonne saritch Knight is
getting back in into play right so we
stop it somehow
can we get the knife
G3 he's going to E4 try to stop noise
yeah okay so now check would be well
because Queen takes
the Knight on F6 and then are you right
because the queen takes but what about
Queen D3 check
Bishop E4 and Knight F6 check and then
Queen takes ah then you just take it
anyway taking a lot of Pawns at the end
yes you are Knight G3 on the board
and that's a that's a trap that would be
easy to fall for Until you realize Queen
takes F6 Magnum is definitely with the
advantage here but with less than one
minute against three minutes almost it's
not going to be once again an easy
conversion it's all about conversion for
Magnus in this event so far by the way
there is a bishop E4 and a queen C1
that's right like if you do something
silly like Queen
you fall immediately into Bishop E4
check that's kind of a big threat that's
that's nasty so maybe Queen E1
and you want just uh but then I go
Knight to E4 right uh 94. you can get a
94 right
it doesn't actually win any material
though
I mean it's just a nice Square to stop
me from jumping to F6
and what did he do even as that look of
oh dear Queen wait a minute just play
Queen to F2 Bishop to E4 and he resigned
oh oh he fell for your trick Yasser you
jinxed him
first that was terrible
well Magnus uh
uh recovering a very very slow start
he's he's notoriously a slow starter but
getting ready for the blitz with only a
one point deficit and the last game
which somehow is still pending yeah the
Lost games seem happy gonna be a draw
right why are we so sure by the way
about the draw
just count right so I think King E4 just
makes a draw right
E5 is what Wesley yeah basically like
anything from the bb5 you want to go to
the B5 Square that's the crucial Square
King takes a A2 there's nothing
at least like get the yeah King A3 King
C4 King A4 at least
Wesley's looking at him King A4 King
burme King C4 King A4 for now I'm at
least kind of guaranteed and King C3
yeah and he go King C3 B5 King B2 and
then King B4
but never mind that should be a draw
whoa Wesley played this move away this
second do we believe it's a draw B6
that's there's like some mutual uh this
one's getting worried that movie did
King D40 blow it no no no no it's it's
still fine it's still fine it's still
fine and he's playing fast so I think he
he figured this out yeah first yes I
thought like you probably see along the
same lines right King A3 right kc5 B4
King B5 B6 and I said yeah okay genius
okay but he has King C4 B5 it's never
too but King C4 King A4 at that point
and then exactly
no but howdy ah then you have King D5
only move right because after B3 take
take take you have King C6 King C6 yeah
so he's holding but maybe at some point
he will have to find the only I find it
uh amusing that uh in his hands
Wesley is holding on to the black queen
I will never let you promote
there's an extra one there's an extra
one there
aha
so he's being nice he's being nice
okay so Shaq is still trying
and by the way Shaq is holding on to the
White Queen
yeah that's it less chance that White's
going to promote it than black
so how to create an interesting right
now
we know King to C3 working to C5
pretty much the same yeah
King the C5 seems somewhat more shall we
say forcing
but now Wesley's hesitating but if you
play King C3 and I go B6
you will go oh yeah I will not go
anywhere so can you see trees yeah so
finally we found one that works yeah if
there's one there's another right King C
I can see four perhaps is uh clever King
C5 yeah then King sifa but he can go
King a five still and then perhaps Force
this uh
I mean he can force this position where
Wesley has to find the only move I'm
guessing yes
Leslie is remarkable and yeah his life
ability to find tricky ways out
um
I mean obviously it's a table based uh
draw but I must say in my studies of
King and pawn and games
I don't ever think I've got this
position on my
study sheet no it's it's a very uh
unusual for sure King B3 King B5 King B2
and I think I think that's what you
don't want to see you don't want to see
I I don't think so
because King A4 King A3 if you allow me
and then B3 right so you think I should
play King to D 44 or King D5 yes wait a
second king D5
[Music]
King D4
King A4 King C4 King C4 we have back on
track and we are back on track right
yeah West Wesley is good wow Wesley is
holding on
maybe even King D6 right now
try to uh approach you from behind
uh-huh
I would be so reluctant to play such a
move but yeah so you psychologically you
want to keep the king it's closer to the
euro even though you have no chance
whatsoever to protect it yeah but you
want to keep the king oh but now we do
have King C6 and maybe even King C7
King C7 I think that forces matters
that's why I want to go to C7 exactly
King C7 when you go King B5 then I go
King the six-pack
King C6 now I go King A6 and at least
I'm taking the opposition big win
but big yeah but the question is what's
all about yeah King D6 King B5 Kingsley
five and we are back back right okay
yeah five yeah there's not much to do
yeah
King A4 King C6 I think this just forces
uh
liquidation King A3 King B5
between a three King B5 only move yes
yes and there you have it King versus
King
wow wow wow wow wow yeah this move this
idea of going King D6 what you were
saying your your natural instinct is to
come back and to defend the pawn on A2 I
was reminded of the comment by Michael
tal after losing his world championship
match he said now the Soviet children
are all very happy they can go back to
learning how to defend their pawns and
pieces rather than learning how to
sacrifice them
and we have the standings after our
rapid Championship the winner of the
rapid championship tournament Miro is
Jordan Jordan won forest and then it's a
huge tie for the second and Wesley we
saw what it takes he is still undefeated
the only in the field who's undefeated
Wesley saw he somewhat slowed down who
sped up surely he's Magnus Carlsen the
world champion he's scoring Five Points
out of a possible six in this uh day
three of play bringing him him to 11 but
Jordan van Forest my goodness
lost two games but look at how many
games he's won to take a lead as we go
into our Blitz
I'm sure we're going to have some news
from Zagreb but as we take a pause
um
and I just want to remind everybody that
tomorrow we will be playing our first
day of Blitz it will be nine rounds so
basically the same round robin that we
had in Rapid a long three days exactly
and then they'll switch colors come
Sunday 18 games of Blitz coming up 18
points also coming up so those standings
that you just saw can change
so now I'm looking at the standings and
the well it's only two points that
separate your guy from my guy I'm still
getting hopeful so thank you again for
winning a couple of games exactly
exactly we wanted to make it a contest
uh Christian Jump Right In uh we see
Wesley so undefeated player but boy he
was close in this round well what I'm
seeing is my pick Magnus Carlson the
world champion surging through the
rankings and only one point behind the
leader Jordan van forest and that gives
me hope maybe one day my pick is going
to win the event I think it would be for
the first time so I'm definitely uh
taking a look at that one of course I'm
mightily impressed with Jordan van
forest and his performance up to this
point this young man came into this
competition as one of the lowest rated
players and he's just exploding I mean
the guy is just playing brilliant just I
have to say he's very well prepared he
plays fast he plays confident and even
when he released some pressure against
alireza he immediately took back over
with that important move C5 that was
crucial if you miss a Tempo at that
point and allowed the king to go to D7
and stabilize as black you're giving
your opponent too many chances he played
the move C5 I'm seeing a very very
courageous Spirit from Jordan in this
event and I really enjoy that and we
also have Alejandro in Zagreb with
shakriar Mama diarf
we're here with shock mamadiarov shocked
you had a topsy-turvy rapid section of
the tournament you beat Magnus Carlson
but you had some problems here and there
how do you evaluate it okay after Magnus
of course I belonged this in the game
against alireza and also today's first
game Maxim it was absolutely winning
position in game and I lose this
position and of course the last game is
absolutely winning position this looks
very easy winning position I think every
move is winning and it was a fantastic
for him because I think end game is
winning I mean it just looks you just go
with King and is winning but uh
obviously he played very fast it is in
game I don't know okay so it was only
one chance for him to play in the game
it was a very good idea rookie rookie
foreign
[Music]
94 is winning very easily and for this
reason I just played in one second this
move Knight E4 after Bishop C7 and I
have certainly Miss Rook d8 move but
after rookie
I think the winning position because
normally it was my idea check if play
King G2 yeah
look of the king's G1 yeah his King's G1
is just check King Gage two I think the
same and they take take a knight F2 this
is a very good and this I think is
winning position but depleting each one
this looks very strange to move but
again I I I after I miss F3 move I mean
F3 that's okay F3 after F3 is very good
chance for him for draw and in the
opinion were you surprised that he held
on no but normalize looks like it is two
points against three and King just to
come and eat all bombs but
uh that's fantastic is but of course
but okay how I don't know I don't know
it does kind of defy the loss of Chess
right outside pass Pawn already yeah I
mean it's Queen C2 is normally it's drop
position I mean very good chance for him
for draw but Queen H6 I think okay of
course I need to play this end game
because it looks you just could go with
Kings and I think too much here about
King D3 I think it's yeah I think I will
take C4 King D3 is winning and King D3
is also it looks very good but it's just
King is very strange King
just again same
okay
yeah oh then this way and right on time
you take your P6 right let's extend this
draw okay just this big Miss I mean
today I wanders in first game and last
game I just plundered these winning
positions to in two winning position I
just got half points and it feels like
getting great positions great stuff from
the opening great tactics what's missing
what's going on I don't know normally uh
when I got these positions like winning
positions of extra material I played
well but today's I mean I played today
two games I really two winning position
I just go to half points and okay I mean
it's a I don't know it's not a set not
problem it's just a Miss in one moves
and two moves well hopefully you can
record for the Bloods are you excited
for it change your face I hope I hope
yeah because of course you after Rapids
okay it's a little bit not easy because
in Rapid we have more times forcing but
in military we just need to push in zip
mode but okay I mean I injured from all
games in this tournament and for this
reason I'm very happy with my chess and
results oh absolutely 18 more points up
for grabs Shaq thank you for the
interview thank you that's it that
concludes the rapid portion of Zagreb
that is just amazing a little unlucky
But Chuck thanks for spending thank you
very much good luck thank you
and give me back my microphone Alejandra
as we uh review 175 000 up for prize
money but also we have our grand Chester
standings after Warsaw Poland and here
they are yes
leading not present here by the way but
will reappear right because remember the
tour participants have to play in the
two Classics that's Bucharest and sinful
cup and they have two out of three right
as far as the Rapids that's why Fabiano
and Lavon are missing uh and there you
see the prize money at the moment and
again 175
000 up for uh grabs in a Zagreb uh with
forty thousand dollars to the winner
whew it's been uh it's been quite some
time these uh last three days uh Miro I
have enjoyed calling the action but as
our colleague Christensen said Christian
said Thrills and Spills along the way
by the way speaking of percentage I
think they still held this 50 or more
than 50 percentage decisive games which
is really impressive exactly exactly
we've been talking about that aspect of
this tournament
15 games nine decisive
and let's go to Zagreb and Anastasia and
Alejandro for final thoughts
Anastasia we had quite a day here in
Zagreb a surging Magnus but that's not
our headliner yeah today uh Jordan One
Forest managed to win actually the rapid
part of the tournament and I'm very
impressed by his play and actually I had
the chance also to interview him today
as well as you Alejandra and he looked
so happy you know he was so really
emotional today and also it's
interesting that the Wesley so is quite
happy with his results so far but and of
course the last game when he managed to
hold this draw it was also a very
important game for him and it was really
nice to see all the players analyzing
right I mean right when they finish
their games they stayed here in the next
to the plane Hall analyzing the position
right oh that was just fascinating for
the players we had nepo we had Magnus we
had mvl everybody was looking at that
pawning game trying to figure out if it
was a draw or not they didn't have the
engine evaluation they were like trying
to fight against each other but
eventually everybody concluded it's a
draw Wesley was right shark just could
to break through on that one by the way
I was talking to mvl earlier today and
talked to him about Jordan like what's
going on what's what's uh the win behind
in silos he says he's a good player and
you shouldn't be surprised that he
scores good points yeah exactly and um I
mean it was really fun to see all this
section and you can still follow them in
Instagram stories so if you want to see
some videos with the players behind
scene you can go to our Instagram
account our social media accounts and
find them of course follow us on
Instagram grandchildstool and guys it
was awesome to call the rapid but I am
waiting for the blitz I cannot wait and
that'll be tomorrow
absolutely thank you Alejandro thank you
Anastasia and here's to review our
predictions because none of you and I'm
ashamed of you all yeah I've chosen uh
Jordan uh my guy faroogia was in there
with a shout Carlson on the outside uh
who do we like going into the Blitz
I still like Magnus guys you still like
Magnus Myan VAR were war with Magnus I
don't know MBL uh when you when you
think about the great Blitz players of
the world I also think Magnus mvl
anakamoras
crazy crazy
basically right so you don't like her no
no I like farusha I like I like them
better after eight rounds of play yeah
fair enough yeah but this gives me hope
right because if couple of rounds ago
you would offer me to you know to switch
the player I would happily jump out of
the nipples
he won a couple of games and you're
feeling it yeah I think I think yeah we
still stand a chance well uh thank you
everybody for uh joining us and sharing
your day remember this weekend is going
to be action non-stop it's see you all
tomorrow yeah see you tomorrow yasa
signing off yeah absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited